.
>>> Good morning, everyone.
Thank you for joining us for
inside baseball, baseball
collections as data.
This morning we're going to
marry a hear a lot about rapid
prototyping, designing,
collaboration, a little bit of
scrambling, maybe a dash of
magic as well.  First I'd like
to introduce you to our director
of digital strategy at the
library of congress, Kate.
Kate's going to share a little
more about the work that's
happening here at the library
and are delighted to have her
here with us.  Thank you.
>> Thank you so much, Meghan.
I'm thrilled to be here to open
today's events.
I'm the library of congress's
director of digital strategy.
And on behalf of the National
Museum of African-American and
culture and
JSTOR, I'd like to welcome
everybody.  We're excited to be
able to share with you a week's
worth of very focused work.  As
you all know, Dr.
Hayden has brought a new vision
to the
library that will be or user
centered and focused on how we
can reach more people and
interact with them on a deeper
level.  And technology, I think,
is a great enabler of that kind
of work.  This event highlights
how we can effectively partner
with our users and create
prototypes that will make us
more effective and efficient.
We'll be publishing a
digital strategy for the Library
of Congress in September.  Which
will describe our plans for
reaching more users with
technology and enabling further
access to our materials.  To
accomplish that work, we're
going to be on labs and their
ability to try and do things and
test our assumptions.  One of
the things I love about the
culture of labs is our -- that
we do things in the open so that
while we're learning, we're
helping others learn.  So we've
learned so much from JSTOR Labs
here this week.  We're thrilled
that they're here with us.
So that's a great
segue into the past week and
today.  It's been a lively week
of looking at
collections in new ways,
engaging users inside and
outside of our walls, and
flash-building.  It's been a
week of shared learning
and a week of demonstrating the
power of computational access to
collections.  We love thinking
about the different ways our
collections can be understood
and the power of computation
brings up a lot of more
opportunities.  Today is going
to be a really thrilling day.
We've got some wonderful
speakers at the head.  And we're
going to get to see some
fantastic datasets and
prototypes which will be useful
to baseball researchers and data
analysis and hopefully can form
a model for other types of
collections.
It's always fun to show what
could be quickly put together
when great minds are together.
We'll be hearing from the
National Museum of
African-American History and
Culture and JSTOR.  And this
afternoon I'm excited to share
that we'll have Clinton Yates,
Rob Ruck and Jordan Ellenberg in
a panel discussion.
Okay.  As the
unofficial empire here, play
ball.
[ Applause ]
umpire here, play ball.
>> I'm Jamie.
Okay, Yay.
So my name is Jamie Mears, and I
work
for the LC Labs team that Kate
mentioned.  I'm going to talk a
little bit -- I'm going to try
to frame the day for you, which
is a big task because it's a
little confusing.
For those of you who dropped in
for the event today, the biggest
point that I want you to know
from the start is that we've
been working since Monday
around the clock to put together
flash-build products to help
people research baseball and
discover our collections.  And
it's kind of crazy that we did
that.  It's very vulnerable
exercise, and it's been really,
really fun.  It's required all
of us to really trust each
other.  And so here we go.  I'm
going to try to help explain why
we did this and why we're here.
So "inside baseball," this is a
look at "Inside Baseball.
"   I wanted to kick off with an
item from the baseball
collection.  It's a picture of
an indoor baseball team in
Chicago, 1897, I believe, and
it's considered to be -- they're
considered to be the first
softball team that ever existed.
They seem more dapper than a lot
of the other baseball pictures
I've seen so far of people,
maybe playing inside, I
don't know, makes you age
better.
This is Inside Baseball to me
when I think about it, which may
be scary to some people here.
So Inside Baseball underneath is
essentially data, and it's so
much work, but it's so worth it.
And so hopefully by the end of
this
presentation, you'll see why I
love this.
So this is a picture of the LC
Labs team.  If we were on a
baseball card, you know how they
used to do those action shots
for teams that were staged.
This is not staged but it's not
very dynamic either.
But this would probably be us,
just kind of standing around and
problem solving together around
a whiteboard.  I wanted to
mention that our team got
Abby potPotter here, me and
Meghan Ferriter who introduced
the day.  Not featured here is
half of our team.
We just expanded to three more
people, and they have joined us
because we are
launching a crowdsourcing
transcription and tagging
application that's going to
launch in the fall.  So if you
-- if this talk makes you
interested in data at all and
you want to take a hand in it,
then that opportunity is going
to happen quite soon.
Okay.
So I wanted to talk a little
about our goals because they
feed directly into
why we did this event this week.
It's difficult for me -- so the
first one is enable
transformational experiences by
connecting users with the
library and its digital
collections.  So some people --
people ask us all
the time, how do you measure
impact?  And the way that we
think about it is
if you see a photograph, for
example, whether it's a dataset
or a single item and it
transforms the way that you
think about American History and
Culture, then we've done our
job.  So that was partly the
impetus for the flash-build this
week.
And then our second
big goal is to prototype ideas
and build relationships with
stakeholders that will realize
the library's digital strategy.
So you heard from Kate earlier.
We're launching a digital
strategy, a
new digital strategy, and its
labs' job to pie plot some of
those ideas in small, safe ways
to see whether or not they work
for the Library of Congress's
environment.
And then the last goal is to
strengthen our community by
sharing our work for
transparency, feedback and
knowledge exchange.  So that's
what we're doing now in a
very ex-treme sense because
we're going to demo something
for you live that no one has
ever seen before.  So another
important point of this whole
week is that we spent a lot of
time documenting all of the
exercises we went through
through the flash-build, all of
the decisions we made around
data transformation.  And that's
something that's a little scary
to do out in the open.  But we
feel it's really important
because we all learn from each
other.
So hopefully by the end of the
day, there will be a link that
we're going to share through
social media, et cetera,
pointing you to where all our
documentation is so that you can
take this back to your own
cultural institutions or
anywhere you work to think about
how you can incorporate
user-centered design into what
you do.
Okay.
And labsllc.gov is our home, if
you want to follow us, you can
sign up for our listserv.  But
essentially, this is the main
place to find, you know,
information about us and the
prototype that we're going to
demo is going to live here in
our experiments page.
Okay.  So LC Labs.
Who are we?  Where did we come
from?  Two years ago, a little
over two years ago now, we were
formed.
And we hosted an event called
Collections of Data, and we've
actually done that two years
running.  In the point of
collections of data
was an all-day symposium talking
about
what does it mean to use data
and cultural heritage
institutions to get the public
to use it, what types of
possibilities are there for
thinking about how to interact
with collections online in
different ways.  And the first
two years, the symposiums were
very talky, just like I'm doing
now.  You know, it was a lot of
experts coming together to
discuss these really important
issues.  But we wanted to do
this year take a spin-off of
collections of data and actually
just build something.
So that's kind of the -- I would
say in some ways this is an
unofficial third year of
collections of data, but we're
taking all the lessons we
learned and actually
incorporating them into the way
that we work.
So what do I mean by collections
of data?
This is an example here of a
tutorial of how to use our API
if you were investigating our
baseball collections which we
have many of.  So one of the
things that we know is that
people are aware perhaps of what
an API is.  It's the underlayer
of information that's underneath
a website that you can make
calls to.  But there's some
intimidation of what it means or
how it could possibly be useful
to someone who happens to
stumble upon our lab site.  So
we've done a lot of work on our
site on a page called LC for
robots of
tu fortorials for you to
investigate our collections
through the data itself.  And I
encourage you to look at that if
you get inspired by this event.
This is another
example of
collections of data.
This is an example of a product
that was built by our innovator
in residence.  So this is the
program that we started, and our
current innovator in
residence is the data artist
here Thorpe.  And the idea
behind it is to try to inspire
people to think about
collections and how to form them
serendipitously in innovative
ways.  And underlying that is
data.  So this example is the
library of color.  And what
you're seeing right now is an
example of a visual collection
where he
took information from every
single
record from prints and
photographs and
essentially compared this to --
took words that you could
extrapolate to color and then
visualized those colors into a
rainbow.  And this is a
screenshot.
But if you were to use the
strap- drop-down and look at our
collection visualized in color,
you'd essentially see blue and
black because it turns out a lot
of titles of books tend to
represent darkness or the ocean
or something like that.
So you can actually, I think,
intuitively work your way
through the
collections and start to
extrapolate
some theories around formats and
titles, plus it's just
beautiful, which is also fun and
valid in its own right.
This is another take on
exploring the library by color.
This is an experiment that
exists on our experiments page
that was made by
Laura Rubel who was a software
librarian residence with us at
LC Labs.  What you're seeing is
one of our photograph
collections extrapolated into
color palettes so each of these
swatches of color represents one
item.  And if you were to click
on it, you'd jump back to our
lc.gov collection and be able to
explore that item.  And she did
visualize the baseball card
collection.  So if you're
curious about seeing
that, I would suggest you go
onto our experiments site and
look at the baseball one because
it's incredibly beautiful and
colorful.  Okay.
So I've talked a little bit
about how we've had people come
to the library to work with us
to experiment with our
collections and our data in new
ways to get the public
interested.
This was a different angle of
trying to do that.  We
essentially wanted a wide swath
of people to create.  And so we
hosted a challenge called the
congressional data challenge.
And the point of it was to get
people to produce some type of
application or
tool with legislative data on
congress.above.gov.  We had two
winners.  We had 17 entries.
They were all pretty stellar.
And these two high schoolers,
Allen
Gomez Tagle and Carter Neilsen
who will be here next week to
get an award in person won the
first place prize.
So we ended up having our first
and second place winners being
high school students out of all
17, which was amazing and also
made us really hopeful that the
future is looking bright, that
there are people who are really
interested in taking our
collections and creating things
out of them in a way that's very
active, and that's definitely
what we want to see.
So you can look at
all the other apps through
challenge.gov.  There's 12 that
were submitted publicly.  Carter
and Allen's is up there, the
U.S. treaties explorer, but
there's a bunch of other ones.
So if you are interested in the
data, I encourage you to take a
look.
Okay.  So where we're going,
what does this have to do with
this week?  So collections of
data essentially doing it
instead of just talking about
it, we were really inspired by
the baseball Americana
collection because baseball has
a lot of stuff.  There's a lot
of data.
It's also a topic that has a
very wide reach.  And so we
thought it would be a way to get
enthusiasts and members of the
general public thinking about
what we're obsessed with, which
is data.
So JSTOR Labs approached us,
wanted to play ball with us,
wanted to do something.  And,
you know, we thought, oh, why
don't we do something around
baseball collections.  That's
something that we could
definitely do together.
So we essentially are being led
by JSTOR through this effort
this week.  They are
facilitating us through the
first data jam that we did as a
team, through the first
flash-build we did as a team.
But we're also competing with
each other because we're both
going to demo our own tools that
we've been working on
separately.  Let's just be real.
It's what's happening.
And so it's been really
fantastic to learn from them.
This is not their first rodeo.
They've done this with a bunch
of other cultural heritage
institutions and it's really
been fantastic.
Another partner -- or
collaborator of ours this week
is the National Museum of
African-American History and
Culture.  So although they
haven't been with us kind of
sweating it out over keyboards
for the past four days, they've
been working with us for the
past several
months to essentially combine
some of their baseball digital
collections with
the library ofLibrary of
Congress'.  Not to give too much
away, but the demo that the team
worked on this week is going to
let you kind of seamlessly view
National Museum of
African-American
History and Culture baseball
items with Library of Congress
items, so it's really, really
special.
And that is what you see here.
So this is an exercise in love
because when you're talking
about bringing data together,
it's really a negotiation of,
you know, what is valuable to
you in your institution and how
you show your collections.  So
this is, I think, one of the
best resources that's going to
come out of this event.
This was the data jam that we
did.  And the whole purpose of
this slide is essentially to say
that there's a lot of people
behind the scenes that worked on
this.
We had curators from our
photographs and prints division.
We had baseball researchers.
And then, of course, our LC labs
team and JSTOR.  It was a full
house of people trying to figure
out how to build things that
would get researchers
interested.
They don't know I put
this slide in.  Another thing
that was really wonderful about
this is that the LC labs team
got to work hand in hand with
Chris
addAdams and a designer.  And we
got to build this tool together
which usually doesn't happen.
We kind of, you know, work in
silos and a project gets passed
around.  But it was awesome to
see everyone's expertise play
out in realtime.
So this is Griff drawing a very
small preview of what you're
going to see later wire frame of
our application that we built.
So hopefully that set the stage
a little bit.  I wanted to make
sure everyone was aware in how
much work has gone into the
work.  For LC Labs, if you're
interested in any of the
experiments that I shared with
you or you want more information
about the congressional data
challenge or other challenges
that might be coming
up, you can e-mail us at
NDI@LSC.
gov, follow us on Twitter
@LClabs, follow us on our
listserv or go to our website.
Okay.  So that's it for me.  So
now I'm going to pass it off to
a collaborator that I just
mentioned, the National Museum
of African-American
History and Culture's museum
specialist,
Courtney Belize and Emily Hough.
[ Applause ]
>> Good morning. I'm Emily, and
this is Courtney.
And we're part of the
digitization
team at the museum of
African-American History and
Culture.  Our team catalogs the
museum's objects, digitizes them
and helps make the collection
information accessible and
discoverable for both users
inside
the museum and outside the
museum.  And today we're going
to talk to you a
little bit about the objects
that we featured in this dataset
for this project and how we
cataloged them and walk through
the data points together.
The goal of the
museum is to present American
history through an
African-American lens and what
is more American than baseball?
Although we knew the sport of
baseball plays a significant
role in the exhibition sports
leveling the playing field, and
we're familiar with some of our
baseball objects, we hadn't
really
ever done a deep dive into the
-- our baseball-related holdings
until we did this project.  Once
we pulled the data together and
began looking at the various
subjects and object types that
connect with the term baseball,
we were not surprised to see
that America's favorite sport
appears all the way through our
collection from Jim Crow's
segregation in Mississippi to
the early days of hip-hop in New
York City.
Looking at the numbers within
the dataset, we have baseball
objects
from 22 states including -- and
the district of ColumbiaDistrict
of Columbia, 16% of our objects
are from
New York city 1/, and 8% of our
baseball-related objects also
have stories to tell about the
American South.
If we compare types of objects,
8% are
items of clothing like jerseys
and hats.  30% are part of the
class of objects
we call memorabilia and, things
like
tickets, programs, pennants,
pin-back buttons and autographs.
The most well-represented class
of objects are photographs and
images, making up 44% of the
dataset.
Analyzing the subject terms
connected to baseball, a
remarkable 34%
of our collection -- baseball
collection, have stories related
to
segregation like this 1920s Wolf
sweater for the Eastern Colored
League.
And 4% of our objects are
related to musicians such as
this Texas Rangers
uniform worn by Charlie Pride.
Before he became one of country
music's most successful artists
ever, Pride was a baseball
player.  He was a pitcher for
the Memphis Red Sox and other
Negro league teams before he
ever kissed an angel good
morning.  Pride is now part
owner of the Texas Rangers and
at 84 years old, still trains
with them every spring.
We're able to connect
baseball across various
collections and subject areas
because we're committed to
consistent cataloging throughout
our
collection using the same
standards, vocabularies and
approach regardless of
department.
This allows us to tie together
thematics reds that appear
throughout the collection.
Things like identity,
resistance, connection and joy.
Starting with baseball, we can
follow the data points through
the three pillars of history,
community and culture that form
the collection.
>> Good morning. We're going to
start with our history
collections.  And since it's
all-star week, it's only
appropriate to start with a
collection object that harkens
back to the beginning.  This
pennant from about 1933
celebrates the Negro league's
east/west all-star game.
The Negro leagues established in
1885 gave African-American
ballplayers who were not
accepted to play in other major
and minor leagues a chance to
play professionally.
The east/west all-star game
began in 1933, the same year
that the MLB all-star game was
established.
The game was generated to start
as a
way for the owners to generate
money essentially.  But the game
became so much more.  It was a
way to help legitimize the Negro
league teams and the
African-American professional
baseball players.  The game was
the sporting event for
African-Americans.
Celebrities like Count Bessie,
Ella
Fitzgerald, Joe Louis and Lena
Horne threw out the first pitch
of the first all-star game.
Though they were celebrated,
they still stood as a stark
reminder that professional
baseball, like many aspects of
American society, was
segregated.  When we look at the
data points, the term
segregation is used to convey
this very important aspect of
history.  The term also links us
to our next object, a poster
about the integration of the
Detroit Tigers.  Nicely and
seamlessly done.
In 1947, Jackie Robinson steps
onto
the field to play for the brook
LingBrooklyn dodgers.  In 1958
the Detroit Tigers were the
second to last team to
integrate.  When Ozzy Virgil Sr.
joined the team.  He was born in
the Dominican republic and was
the first person of African
descent to join the Tigers and
was also the first Dominican to
play in MLB.
On June 6th, 1958, Virgil went 5
for 5 in his debut with the
Tigers.  And despite occurring
more than ten years after
Robinson's first game, the
integration of the Tigers was
still met with protest from
staunch segregationists
including Detroit city council
member Billy Regell.  He was
also a former shortstop for the
Tigers.
He opposed Virgil's point
appointment to the team.  This
poster sends a clear message
about his policies and beliefs
and gives us a glimpse into race
relations in the city of Detroit
in 1958.  As you can see,
several subjects have been
attributed to this object
including segregation, civil
rights and race relations.
Using the term race relations,
we can
move to our next related be on
object type, a magazine from
1960 featuring notable
African-American athletes.
As professional sports became
integrated, African-American
athletes soon became household
names.  Though African-American
athletes became mainstream, they
were still viewed as other.
As evidenced by this issue of
sportSport magazine.  The title
is "sports: Special issue."
The Negro in American sports.
And it still conveys this idea
that African-American athletes
needed to be looked at
separately from their white
counterparts.  The term race
relations was used for this
object because sports magazine
was founded in 1946 and was one
of the first national sports
publications and serves as an
example of how African-American
athlete s 'as' achievemented
were covered.  It included wilt
Chamberlain, Willie Mays, Gibson
and Jackie Robinson.  From a
data perspective, all of these
athletes become subjects of the
collection objects so that this
object appears when any of the
aforementioned names are
searched.
Let us look at the data point
Jackie Robinson to move along to
our next dataset.
Our next set of
objects focus
around NMHC's collection theme
of community.  Using the subject
term Jackie Robinson in a search
of our internal databases brings
up a variety of objects
including a ring, magazines and
photographs.  The collection
objects span different aspects
of Robinson's career not only as
a baseball player but as a
family man and activist who
impacted both baseball and
African-American communities.
For instance, let's
take a look at this photograph
from 1954 of Jackie Robinson and
Harry Owens.  Here Robinson is
out of uniform, receiving a
lifetime membership award to the
Irene Kaufman settlement house
in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania, for
his charity work.  The
photograph was taken by a
community photographer named
Charles Harris.
Harris was had a connection to
baseball, actually, because he
helped
found and was a player for the
Crawford Colored Giants who
later became the Pittsburgh
Crawfords.  There's another
little baseball connection in
there.  But Harris was known as
one shot, not in a reference to
his baseball career, but in
reference to his photography.
He was -- his photography mainly
focused on the Hill District,
which is an African-American
community in Pittsburgh, and his
more than 80,000 images provide
one of the most complete
documentations of a minority
community in the United States.
When cataloging this
photograph, it's important that
the data
not only leads ss researchers to
Jackie Robinson but also to
Teenie Harris, the notable
community photographer.  Using
another data point from this
object, the date, 1954, it will
lead us to another photograph
taken by another
community photographer, Ernest
C. Withers.
Around 1954, Withers took this
portrait of Connie Morgan.
Withers documented
African-American
communities in the segregated
South for 60 years.  Morgan was
the third woman to play
professional baseball in the
Negro league.  She joined the
Indianapolis crowns in 1954 as a
second baseman and was
replaced the first woman who
joined the
league, Tony stoneStone.  Many
saw women having join the teams
as a gimmick increased sales
after integration with MLB, many
journalists who every coed the
leagues often wrote about the
women's skill and talent as
players.
For example, an article covering
the
Clowns' game on May 29th, 1954,
featured
in the Afro-American, quote,
Morgan electrified over 6,000
fans when she went far to her
right to make a
sensational stop, flipped to
stop shortstop and started a
lightning double play against
Birmingham.  End quote.  The
great double play excited this
large community of fans.  And
what we found that's so
prevalent throughout our
museum's baseball collections is
the tie to community.  This time
let us turn to the object
type portraits to see how this
portrait of Morgan can link us
to another object reflecting
community within the museum's
collections.
>> The object type portraits
brings us to the collection of
the photographer the reverend
Henry C. Anderson.  Anderson was
the local portrait
photographer in Greenville,
Mississippi, from 1947 through
the 1970s.  Nearly every member
of the black community of
Greenville had their portrait
taken by Anderson at one point
or another.
Anderson documented all aspects
of Greenville's family and
community life during Jim Crow
segregation including
new babies, birthdays, weddings,
anniversaries, graduations,
church groups, community clubs
and, of course, the Little
League teams like this one here.
So we've just seen how our
subject terms can take us
through several community
photographers.
But if we use the classification
media arts photography where all
of our photographs and images
are grouped
under, we can expand and find
the collection of hip-hop
photography where perhaps
surprisingly we also find
baseball.
This leads us to the culture
section of our objects.
In this photograph of KRS1 taken
by Al
Pereira in 1991, the rapper
sports the iconic pinstripes of
the New York Yankees.
KRS1 is an influential emcee
from the South Bronx.  He
started his career as part of
the
duo Boogie Down Productions
before going solo after the
shooting death of his partner,
DJ Scott la rock.
And being from the South Bronx,
KRS1's affinity for Yankees gear
signifies his ties to the
birthplace of hip-hop.  Using
athleticwear and baseball teams
in particular in this way is a
common
style for hip-hop stars like
KRS1.  And if we follow the term
hip-hop, we'll see another
example.
This is perhaps the supreme
example of the intersections of
baseball, music and fashion, the
iconic baseball cap.
I learned recently, yesterday,
that
baseball historians credit Tom
Selleck with popularizing the
off-the-field baseball cap trend
in the 1970s.  But I think we
can all agree that
hip-hop is largely responsible
for the longevity of the trend.
This purple Atlanta Braves cap
from
the rapper bigBig Boi was made
by the preeminent manufacturer
of baseball caps
newNew Era Cap Company which has
been making caps since 1920.
This particular hat was a
limited
release in 2013 in conjunction
with Big Boi's solo album,
vicious lies and dangerous
rumors.
In early June 2013, fans who
attended
a CD signing by Big Boi at the
New Era store in Atlanta also
received this limited-edition
hat inspired by the album.
Big Boi and Outkast is known as
the group that brought southern
hip-hop into
the mainstream and Big Boi is
seldom
seen without his signature
Braves cap to rep his hometown
of Atlanta.  This hat has the
subclassification clothing
fashion.  But if we follow the
main class clothing or the
subject term clothing and dress,
we end up back in the
traditional world of baseball
with This
Cardinals jersey that was game
born by Curt Flood in '66.  He
was an all-star player and a
center fielder for The
Cardinals, he won Gold
Glove seven consecutive seasons
from 1963 to 1969.  And during
Flood's 11 seasons on the
team, the Cards won three
pennants and earned two World
Series rings.  When Flood
refused to accept a trade
away from The Cardinals in 1969,
his talents to the reserve
clause helped usher in the free
agency system which
was transformative for the
culture of baseball.  Flood
wrote a letter to the baseball
commissioner reading, "after 12
years in
the major leagues, I do not feel
I am a piece of property to be
bought and sold irrespective of
my wishes.  I believe that any
system which produces that
result violates my basic rights
as a citizen and is inconsistent
with the laws of the United
States and of the several
states.
"   Flood's subsequent lawsuit
against majorMajor League
Baseball was unsuccessfully
argued in front of the Supreme
Court in 1972 which sided with
the league.
But it eventually led to the end
of
the reserve system a few years
later.
26 years later with the Kurt
Curt Flood Act congress declared
baseball subject to antitrust
laws like any other corporation.
Flood is also responsible for
the 10-5 rule which is also
known as the Curt
Flood rule that states when a
player has played for a team for
five straight years and played
in the major leagues for a total
of ten years, they have to give
the club their consent to be
traded.
Although Flood's legacy is
larger than
the time he spent playing with
The card
the Cardinals, our final object,
many roundtree radio.
Roundtree was a diehard fan
living in Gibson County,
Indiana.
Her husband, Herman, bought her
this radio to listen to the
games and keep up with her
favorite team.  The story is a
favorite of mine because she
reminds me of my own grandmother
who at 94 years old never misses
a Cardinals game.
>> Well, thanks for taking the
little journey through our
collections.  And it's just a
small sample of the
collections that we shared for
the event with LLC.  As this
graphic shows, by following a
variety of data points, we've
been able to share and explore
this group of baseball-related
collections from the Negro
leagues to hip-hop.  We were
able to connect each object
based on a set of terms,
classifications and cataloging
fields.  However, we could have
utilized a totally different set
of terms and data points to come
up with a totally different set
of objects.  That's the exciting
part about our
collaboration with LLC and JSTOR
and the flash-build team who
have taken a deep dive into our
data.  What is important is that
the data is consistent and
clean.  And so that way people
can utilize it in ways that we
can't even imagine.  On behalf
of Emily and myself, we
would like to thank our
digitizeation team, the
catalogers who painstakingly
make sure our records are
accurate and consistent, the
curators who review all
of our records, Doug, Laura,
Elaine and Damian, sports
curator, for their support on
this project.  The team at
Library of Congress,
especially Julia hick Hickey,
and the team at JSTOR and,
again, the flash-build team who
worked all this week and
participated in this great
event.  Thank you for having us,
and I hope you enjoy the rest of
your day.
[ Applause ]
>> All right. Thanks so much to
the team.
Next we have Alex Humphries from
JSTOR
Labs who's going to come up and
share about what their wonderful
team is and what they've been up
to.  And you'll see the first
demo, hopefully.
[ Laughter ]
>> I don't get to see the
presentation.  Or I do from a
very strange vantage point.  Hi,
everybody.  I'm Alec Humphries.
I'm the director of JSTOR Labs
.  And I want to start just by
thanking the Library of Congress
for being such
amazing hosts and going on this
very
quick adventure with us.  A lot
of things happen in a week, and
they have been so supportive and
eager and at every step along
the way just wanted to jump in
with both feet and do.  And we
find in our team that learning
by doing is just the best
possible way.  And we'll share,
as we go, some of the things
that we've learned.
So first, a little
bit of context just for those of
you who aren't
familiar with JSTOR or the JSTOR
Labs team.
JSTOR is a part of a nonprofit
called Ithaca which helps the
academic
community embrace digital
transformation.
We have a number of different
brands within it, dealing with
digital
preservation, with art and
strategy and research.
JSTOR is a digital archive of
academic literature primarily.
So it's got 10 million articles
and
tens of thousands of academic
books,
spanning centuries of the
scholarly record.  So these are
the academic journals that if
you're writing, if you're a
scholar or writing your
dissertation, you're doing that
research.  And you do that often
these days online with tools
like JSTOR.  It's especially
prominent in the humanities and
social sciences, and it has a
number of -- it's
multidisciplinary.  So if you
are anywhere within those
fields, you'll often dip into
JSTOR.
There we go.  The JSTOR Labs
team is a relatively
small team within that
organization.
There's five, six, seven of us.
And our job is to build
experimental tools.
And we sort of show the future
of what research can look like.
We do it -- and the best way to
see that is through some
examples which I'll walk you
through in just a second.  We
approach all of these projects
collaboratively.  Wherever
possible we work with partners
like the Library of Congress
here.  And we do so openly.  So
we share all the work that we
develop.
We share the code if we can, the
content wherever copyright
allows and make that as open as
possible.
And we also do it as quickly as
possible all the way down to
doing things in one week.  So I
think it will be helpful just to
get a feel for that to see a few
of the things that we've done in
the past.  These are a little
bit more polished than what
you'll see at the end.
But they'll give you a feel for
what we've done.
So if we can jump to the
browser, that would be
wonderful.
There we go.
Okay.  So the first
project was -- we did
this just across the street at
the Shakespeare library,
developed maybe a couple years
ago.
And this is
understandingUnderstanding
Shakespeare.  So if you're
studying Shakespeare, it has all
of the plays of Shakespeare, and
I'll go ahead and click on any
one.  It has all of the plays of
Shakespeare and all of their
cast.  And what we were trying
to do is find a new way for
those people studying and
writing about Shakespeare to
research that work.
So you'll see this is the text
of Hamlet.
The foal library has these
amazing
digital addition editions of
Shakespeare which are openly
available.  When we approach
these projects, they're not sort
of transactional.  They're not
-- they're very open and
collaborative.
And I describe them often as
play dates.  You have your toys
and I have my toys and let's go
play in that sandbox.  And their
toys were these digital editions
of Shakespeare.  So if you see,
the play on the left, and that's
from Folger.
If you click on one of these
numbers, each one of those is
the number of articles in JSTOR
that quote that specific line.
And we have that for every line
of every play of Shakespeare.
And then if you hover over any
of those, you can -- any of the
thumbnails, you can see how it
quotes that article, quotes that
particular line.  And if you're
a student, it can help you
interpret it.  If you're a
scholar, you can see how that
line has been interpreted
through the ages.
And if you've got a digital
humanities bent, you can -- we
have an API for this
so that you can build
visualizations on the how
Shakespeare has been studied
and quoted through two centuries
of academic literature.
So this was -- we released a
couple years ago.  This is the
kind of tool that we build.
This has had a really great
response.  It's now being
included in sill buy.  Teachers
often tell us that this is a
really great way for students to
first dive into academic
literature which can
be really daunting and hard with
keyword search.  It can be --
they're used to Google and going
to the library.  And this is a
very easy way to get into that.
We're now just, to tease
something,
we're currently, who working on
an expansion called
Understanding Great Works which
we hope to go live later
this summer, which will be this
same functionality but for more
than Shakespeare.
It will include the kingKing
James
Bible as well as a selection of
British literature that we're
working on with the studies in
English literature journal.  So
we're really excited about that.
And if you're interested, follow
JSTOR Labs, follow me on
Twitter, and we'll let you know.
Or JSTOR.
So that's one tool.
We built the core of this
functionality in a previous labs
week.  And then we spent a lot
of time making it look prettier
and be a little bit more perfect
and adding the rest of the
plays.  So let's jump to another
example of something that we've
done.  Text analyzer.
As I said, academic research can
be daunting and challenging.
And in various ways.
And text analyzer, we envisioned
as a different way of doing
research to overcome some of the
hurdles.  So text analyzer -- so
for those of you who aren't
familiar with it, academic
research is often done through
either citation mining, meaning
you follow bibliography one to
the next to the next or by
keyword search like you would do
in Google but in an academic
database or in something called
Google Scholar.  But those
keywords and all of that can be
challenging to a new student.
And if you're doing the citation
mining, you can get stuck in a
particular -- in a silo.  So
what text analyzer does is it
changes that by instead of
searching with words, you search
with a document.  So if you've
either found an article that is
already perfect and about what
you're writing about, or if
you've written the first draft
of your paper, you can upload
it.  So if we can drag the
sample document over, you just
drag and drop it over.  And what
it does is it reads the
document, and it figures out
what the document is about.  And
it does that not just by looking
at the words but the implied
words.  It uses a technology
called natural language
processing and topic models to
figure out the implied words in
addition to the explicitly
mentioned ones.  It calls
attention to those, tells you
what it found, suggests another
selection of them in case
there's some that are really
important to you, and
then gives you articles and
JSTOR articles and book chapters
in JSTOR that are about the same
materials.  You can then, you
know, adjust the -- we call it
the equalizer at the top, which
is a metaphor that probably
nobody gets anymore.
[ Laughter ]
You can add new terms.  And then
when you find the articles you
want, you can download this.
This just won an award a couple
weeks ago, which we're really
proud about, proud of.  And this
is available right on the JSTOR
site.  All these tools that we
build are openly available.
The access to the JSTOR
Scholarship, that will often
come through your institution.
But if you're not a member of a
university or a library, much of
that content is available for
free.  Some of it with
registration.  Some of it is
pure open access.
Okay.  That was the
other example of something we've
done before.  Let's get to the
fun stuff of what we actually
did this week.  So if we can go
back to the PowerPoint.
Great.  We showed you that.  We
showed you that.  All right.
So first of all, we wanted to
build -- we knew that we wanted
to build a tool about baseball.
And what I'll do is I'll walk
you through the process, sort of
the story of this project.
It's the story that we've been
leading the Library of Congress
team through
this week and sort of enjoying
that process with them.
I will say every time we do
this, it's different.  We're
learning all the time and trying
new experiments.  This is the
first time we've done sort
of the parallel play of two
teams working evidently in
competition.  Here I thought it
was like the all-star game where
it didn't matter, and it turns
out it's like the all-star game
where it totally matters.
[ Laughter ]
But that's okay.  We're up for
that.  We're up for the battle.
So let me walk you through this
process.  This process -- we
talked about it, I should say,
as something that happens all in
one week.  It's true.  A lot of
work goes on in that week.
But you can't -- I mean, you run
a
marathon of all in one, you
know, for me, five-hour period.
But there's a lot of work to
prepare for these weeks.  So I
don't want to minimize all of
that preparatory work.  That's
really important and it helps us
to run fast these weeks.  So
I'll walk through those -- that
process a little bit.  And then
we'll show you what we came up
with at the other end.
Okay.  So I mentioned earlier
when describing
the Folger -- understanding
Shakespeare
project that we treat these
projects kind of like play
dates.  And we just decide what
is the sandbox.
When we talked to the Library of
Congress team, they suggested
organizing this around the
baseball Americana
exhibit because baseball had so
much interest generally.  It was
multidisciplinary.
And there could be a lot of
interest
and multidisciplinary in a way
that
aligns well with J JSTOR's
collection.  It's really
exciting.  And I will say
personally I'm such a baseball
nerd.  I'm so happy that we
could do this.  There was no way
that we were not doing this as
soon as it was suggested.  This
has been so much fun, especially
to meet some of my favorite
baseball writers through this
process.
So we knew we wanted to work
with baseball.  But what exactly
were we going to do with
baseball?  We wanted a little
bit more definition.
And because the Library of
Congress team had their content
and JSTOR had our content, and
they're not exactly the same.
They're quite different.  And
then when you bring in the
Smithsonian, the National Museum
of African-American History and
Culture, their content, we were
really interested in finding
ways to bring all of that
content together to tell a story
and really make it sing.  And so
we were interested in trying to
do that using linked open data,
which I won't get into the
technology of because I'd
probably mess that up.
But linked-open data is also
called the smart web.  It's more
than just links, but it knows
about the information.  And
we've been working through that
with Wikidata to enable that.
So I'll show you a little bit
about what comes from that.
So the idea here was multiple
corpora, multiple collections of
content and using linked open
data to connect them.  That's
what we wanted to find a way to
do.
I'll tell you a little bit about
the content in JSTOR and how we
went about collecting that data.
We'll probably publish some
blogs or something that get into
this in more detail.  But just
so you have the context for
that, we started with -- by
selecting a set of content in
JSTOR that is about baseball.
We did that using a topic model
similar to what powers text
analyzer that you saw.  It
looked at all of the words
within
every article to find out the
likelihood that an article is
about baseball, even if the word
is not used.  And we've ended up
coming up with
about 25,000 articles through
the
centuries of content in JSTOR,
articles and chapters that were
about baseball.
We then used some,
again, natural language
processing to pull out the
people and places and
organizations from those
articles.
So that we could connect it into
the other -- to the other
collections.
We then used Wikidata to limit
those people, places and
organizations to those related
to baseball.  Not all of the
people in every article was a
baseball person.  We wanted to
keep it focused on really do a
deep dive on baseball.  And that
allowed us to krael what's
called create what's called a
knowledge graph.  And then we
were able to plug into that
knowledge graph the material
from
Library of Congress and
Smithsonian and also some
material
-- some additional data that's
in Wikidata.
And that's as geeky as we'll
get.  At least that kind of
geeky.  There's so many kinds of
geeky that we embrace.  That's
the preparation on the
technology side, but that's not
all that we do in preparation
for these weeks.
If we're building a tool for
baseball researchers, people
studying baseball, we have some
theories about what might be
helpful.  We know how people
research generally.  But we
don't know the exact issues
facing baseball researchers.
And so we solve that problem by
talking to them.
We did, I think, seven
interviews with baseball
researchers of all sorts.  I
talked to my favorite sports
journalist in the world.
We talked to Joe Poznanski, he's
awesome.  We talked to
historians of baseball, cultural
studies people.
We talked to students and
scholars.  And in doing that, we
tried to understand what are
their challenges?  What are the
things that they have to
overcome that's specific to
baseball?  We had to understand
their goals and their practices
so that we could help them
achieve their goals a little
faster or overcome one of the
hurdles.  And so some examples
-- and this, I
should say, this Joe Perlman is
not a real person.  This is the
embodiment of those seven.
We sort of chewed them up,
wrapped them up and put them
into one personification, and
it's Joe.  Who's a fine guy.
So, for example, everybody we
talk to that talks baseball,
history-related classes said
that on the first day of class,
they had to overcome the fact
and tell their students that
this class is not about last
night's game.
It's not about how Bryce Harper
is really stinking this year.
It's about looking at America
and the
story of America, race relations
and labor relations and
capitalism and all of these
wonderful story -- and hopes and
dreams, but it's looking at the
story of America through
baseball.  And the walk-through
that we just got of the National
Museum of African-American
History and Culture was such a
great embodiment of that story.
It was really wonderful.
And all of these people that we
talked to got as excited about
those stories and wanting to be
able to tell them either through
their books or their lectures,
we wanted to find ways to make
it even easier for them to do
so.
So that was the work we did over
the past couple months, leading
up to Monday.
When we all came down here.
And the first thing we did on
Monday was -- I think Jamie had
a picture of
this as well -- was lead a
design jam.  And these are
called a few different things.
Sometimes called design jams.
I've called them idea jams.
Design studio sometimes.
They're various ways -- it's a
structured brainstorming
technique.
And there's a few different
steps that you go through.  And
the first one is the one you see
here on theseThese Post-it notes
that Jessica -- who's awesome
and in the back -- is ably
leading.
And it's a way to highlight and
bring together all of that
research on users and baseball
researchers that we had done,
sort of brainstorming what are
their big goals?  What are the
tasks that they need to try to
achieve?  What are the hurdles?
Because those can spark ideas
for what we can do to make -- to
help them.
From there, this was all -- this
design jam was a couple hours.
It was a quick brainstorming
session.
We did something called an 8x8,
which is what you see here.
You see pages and pages of
pieces of paper with 8 squares.
And everybody in the room worked
silently, had eight minutes to
draw eight different ideas.
They then presented their ideas
to the entire room.  And we did
it again, sharing those ideas.
And it's a really wonderful way
to
very quickly come up with lots
of ideas.  And these were all
based on and responding to the
empathy map.  They build on it,
helping each one would help a
user achieve their goals or
overcome a hurdle.
And some of the ideas aren't
fully formed.  None of them are
fully formed.  Some of them are
more fully formed, but they help
each other, and it's a very
generative approach to
brainstorming.
We then ended the
design jam by dot voting.
Everybody had three dots, could
choose the things that were most
exciting, and that gave us a
heat map of the ideas that were
most exciting.
From there -- so we ended that
with
five or six general ideas that
we were excited to explore.  But
we needed to have a way to
choose between those.  And one
of the Hallmarks and one of the
important parts of these labs
weeks
is it's focused effort, but it's
iterative effort even within the
week.  It's not just one week of
work.  We've had baseball
researchers coming in to pretty
much every day this week.  And
at each step, we'd be showing
baseball researchers our works
in progress.  Where we are so
far.  And using their feedback
to help us make decisions.
So at this point, we had -- we
created a set of paper
prototypes.  And you saw a
picture in Jamie's
presentation of Grif doing this
on the LC team.  Paper
prototypes of different ways
that we could go about using
linked-open
data, to help baseball
researchers do this.  There's a
map.
There was a chrome filter that
gave us a baseball lens when
you're reading about anything.
And then there's this idea
called cultural history baseball
cards.  And that's the one that
we ended up running with.
So then the rest of the week --
so by Tuesday, we knew what we
wanted to build.  It might have
even been Monday afternoon.  So
then it was about rapidly
refining and making -- turning
that idea into a
thing that actually exists in
the world.  So this -- so I'll
show you quickly what that
evolution looked like.
And then we'll get to the actual
site.  So this was the design
jam sketch.
You can see it's pretty unclear
what it is.  It's very sketchy.
There's a little bit of a flow
there.  And sometimes with
these, you'll have multiple
sketches, all talking about the
same idea.  And we'll bring
those together.  That turned
into the paper prototype,
which turned into the first
design mock-up which we'd show
on screen to users to get
feelings for whether they liked
-- whether they thought the idea
could be useful, where they were
confused, what made sense.  At
this point people were getting
confused between baseball cards
and like they thought this was a
collection of baseball cards.
They weren't seeing the links to
the
-- to the materials.
And there were all sorts of
other problems, too.  That's why
we do the research.  And that
makes it kind of fun and
exciting.
This is a further
refinement of the design.  And
so now you can see on the
baseball card for Jackie
Robinson, the cultural history
baseball card, you know, on a
baseball card, if you're
familiar with them, there's
often physical -- there's the
stats.  Their batting average,
their E.R.A.
, year-by-year on the lower --
on the back of the card.  But on
the cultural history baseball
cards, you can get that stuff,
those baseball stats, at
baseballreference.com or any
other wonderful place.  Instead
we have stats about their
cultural history.
So these are links to and stats
about the scholarly articles
about Jackie Robinson, the
number of photos or videos
or objects that are available in
the different collections.  So
that's Library of Congress and
Smithsonian, Wikidata.  So it
sort of gives a snapshot of how
much information we have.  And
then you can dive into it.
So with that, I think
we should switch over to Chrome
and see where it is.  See what
it looks like.
This is the -- there we go.
Quick, you know, caveat.  This
is a week of work.  So what
you're going to see is
definitely a work in progress.
There will be parts that look
great.  There will be some parts
that are a little bit buggy
still.
And you get to do that when it's
only a week.  We're trying to
focus enough to give an idea of
what this actually is.
So what we have is the cultural
history baseball cards brought
to you by the JSTOR Labs team.
And the idea is that you can
pick a player or historical
figure, see their cultural
history card, and then browse
through the primary and
secondary resources about them.
These are organized right now by
the number of articles in JSTOR
about each of these.  And what's
fun about this -- and if you
even show the next 25 or
whatever -- it's first of all,
it's not just players.
You have Branch Rickey, billBill
James, Marvin Miller.  This is
not just the players of
baseball.  This is the history
of baseball sort of told here,
which is really exciting.
We envisioned before we go live,
we'll have more than just the
article -- number of articles on
this home page.  It will include
the number of videos and images
that we have as well.
Then when you click through to
an individual file, who do we
have?  Hammering Hank.  We have
the baseball card that has the
data of number of articles and
images and videos if we have
them, physical objects.  We're
sort of still working on the
classifications and how we map
those to
the library's and Smithsonian's
classifications.  So those are
at the top.  And then you can
browse through.  You can see all
of the articles right there,
click through them to get access
to them on JSTOR.
Or if you want to look at the
images, it brings together the
different images from all the
sources.  You can browse through
those images and then get access
to those images where they're
available, the high-resolution
image, perhaps, that's on the
museum's site or the library's
site.  Then there are some
printed materials here as well.
And I'd just encourage -- I mean
-- so there's a lot of exploring
that you can do.  All organized
around people.
When we talked to the
researchers and one of the
things that led to this was a
lot of them did want people.
They were interested in how to
connect
the different -- the materials
related to each person.
They would say that, you know, I
know I'm doing research -- I'm
telling this particular story,
and I don't know if this
archive, you know, is available
at the Hall of Fame.  Is it
available here?  So if I could
have a way to connect those and
bring those together, it could
be valuable.  They also
described that when they first
start their research, they start
with the secondary literature.
So that would be the scholarly
articles in JSTOR.  And then
they'd do a deep dive into the
contextual material.  But that
depends.  For students, they may
benefit from seeing the pictures
that help bring the history to
life and tell some of the
stories like we heard just in
the presentation from the
National Museum of
African-American History and
Culture.
I think that's enough
demo.
We could keep clicking around,
but let's go back to the
presentation so we can get to
questions.
One thing I should say is that
this -- I see this right now and
the team sees this right now as
probably a little bit
more of a proof of concept than
full-fledged, you know, research
tool ready for heavy lifting.
This is more of an idea and an
evocation of that idea to help
people understand what it looked
like but there's still work to
do.  Oh, I get to click.  So
there's still work to do.
So what we'll do, just so you
know, is
over the coming week or two,
we'll fix some of the things
that you might have
seen, the alignment issues, the
bugs
that we deftly managed to avoid,
and then we'll release it as a
proof of concept.  It will be
available on the JSTOR site.
You can follow me on Twitter.
I'll announce it, and we'll
encourage everybody to explore
it and use it.  And I'll
probably give some presentations
about it, conferences and such.
Just to share what we've learned
along this way.  Along this
journey.
We do see some opportunity for
further development.  And the
first one is, I think for this
to be a really valuable tool,
the amount of collections and
data that's included in it needs
to be more robust.  JSTOR's
great.  The collections at the
Library of Congress and the
National Museum of
African-American History and
Culture, that's some really
wonderful material.  But it
feels still a little -- I think
there's even more that we can do
by bringing in, for example, the
digital public library ofDigital
Public Library of America or
some other materials and beefing
that up.  So that would be work
that we would
love to explore sometime in the
future.
We also would love to explore
some crowdsourced improvement,
the knowledge graph that we have
is -- there are going to be
errors in it.  That's the nature
of how -- what it looks like to
bring this material
together, photographs
miscategorized or things like
that, so we'd love to have an
opportunity for people to help
improve that.  Especially in a
field like baseball
where there's so many citizen
experts
who can help us do that.
And then the last
area for opportunity -- and
again, we'll see when
we can explore these -- is
expanding the concept beyond
baseball.  They are baseball
cards but we can call them
trading cards.
But the idea of using people as
an explorer -- as an exploratory
tool to multiple collections is
really exciting.  This is sort
of a front end to some of the
work that's being -- that's
working
in linked-open data and
Wikidata.  And you can imagine
this same kind of
exploratory tool for people of
the Civil
War or famous writers or
anything like that.
And so we'd be interested in
exploring any of those.
So before we get to
questions, I want to thank you
for being here and Library of
Congress again.  And perhaps
most importantly, I want to
thank the JSTOR Labs team.  So
if you're on the JSTOR Labs
team, stand up.
We have Jared and Siobhan and
Jessica and Matt and Ron and
Beth is sitting down.  She was
sort of a double agent this
week.
[ Applause ]
They're amazing.  And I am so
deeply privileged to be able to
work with these guys who can
pull this together.  My main job
this week was to buy coffee.
And I knocked it out of the
park.
[ Laughter ]
All right.  Thanks.  Are there
any questions?  Yeah.  Or
comments.
>> (Away from mic).
>> There's a microphone.
>> Yeah, hi.
My name is Hollis Gentry and I'm
a special with the
African-American history museum.
I'm also employed with the
Smithsonian library and a
longtime person with JSTOR and I
love JSTOR.
>> We love you too.
>> After registering for this, I
went online to play with your
text, the drop and drag.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> And I have one word for you.
It is absolutely awesome.  For
someone who's done a
considerable amount of research
in trying to find
related data on just anything,
any given subject, because I do
reference, you know.
>> Yeah.
>> It was amazing.
>> Oh, that's so wonderful to
hear.
>> I was typing, for example, we
have a transcription project
where we're digitizing records
of federal government records,
millions of documents.
>> Yeah.
>> And I just typed in one
sentence.  I created a document.
And all I said was, you know,
the bureau was founded on such
and such a date, Washington, D.
C., and it generated thousands
of hits for me.
>> Yeah.
>> So all I want to say is keep
up with whatever you're doing.
>> Oh, well, thank you.
>> And in terms of trying to
figure out
ways to apply this, you want to
touch with universityies like
you're doing already with
scholars.  But there are
different nuances to that
research that I think you're
going to find as you reach out
to the universities and the
different subject areas.  But,
again, all I can say, it was
awesome.
>> Thank you. Thank you.
>> I didn't have to have any
training, how to learn how to do
it.  I looked at it.  I said let
me play with it.
In less than ten minutes, it
generated all that material.
>> I hope somebody is getting
quotes on
this, because, dang, that's a
wonderful testimonial.  Thanks
so much.  Any other questions or
comments?  And we'll be around
over break and later.  Over
there.
>> (Away from mic).
>> There's a microphone coming
down to you.
Orioles fan.
>> Hi. I'm Jordan Ellenberg.
I'll be on a panel later this
afternoon.  I'm curious just
because I'm sort of naive about
sort of how this information is
controlled and what access is
had to what.
I mean, cultural baseball cards,
you wanted to, let's say, for
each player, I want to see every
time that player was quoted in
the newspaper, like every single
thing they said, those archives
exist.  What are the barriers to
somebody like you being able to
just build that in?  So I see
the complete journalistic record
of that -- of that player?
>> The barriers to that access
have to do with access.
I mean, a lot of the
in-copyright material -- you
know, when we were talking to
the researchers, showing them
this, one of the first things
they said was exactly what you
said.  Like oh, my gosh, I want
to see, you
know, how newspapers talked
about Roberto Clementi when he
was just on the team and they
were, you know, he was forced to
be called Bob.  I mean, the
language was terrible.  And I
want to see that and I want to
show it to my students and to
help them understand the context
for it.  The biggest challenge
to that has to
do with access and copyright
which are reasonable things.
The way to overcome that is
through partnerships with people
who have, you
know, people like maybe pro
creates or others who have the
aggregations of newspapers and
then we can create pathways
through there.  It's a little --
it's another -- it's
a bigger challenge to do that
than with the open material that
we have with the Library of
Congress.  So we often, when
we're doing these
weeks, focus on the open
material because it's easy to
experiment really rapidly and
not worry so much about that.
And then once we prove the value
of this is a really nifty way of
doing research, then approaching
those copyright holders or
people who have access to those
databases.  Does that answer
your question?
>> Awesome, thank you.
>> Any other questions?
Okay, well, thank you very much.
And I want to see what the
Library of Congress did because
it's competition.
[ Applause ]
>> Hello.
All right.
So I have a lot of -- we're
going to start with the starting
lineup.
So this is our team.
Here on your left.  Every team
strength is in its lineup.  And
this is ours.
We have Meghan Ferriter who did
a lot of planning for the
overall event and did a lot of
coordination on our team.  Jamie
Mears who you met earlier who
was also very important.
Myself, Abby Potter.  We're all
part of the Library of Congress
labs team.  We worked with folks
from the office of chief
information -- office of the
chief information officer, Chris
Adams,
and Grif Friedman and visiting
archivist Julia Hickey who we'll
hear more about what we did with
our baseball data.  And we had a
lot of great help from our
summer class of interns who are
also around here.
You'll see them, Eileen Jakeway,
Yasira, Anda and Courtney
Johnson.
We were also coached by the
JSTOR Labs
Beth Dufferch rt helping us
clearly define our goals and
move us on over the week.  So
this is a great team.  And we
started there.
But actually, we started before
then during our warm-up which is
our data prep.  And I'm going to
let Julia talk about that.
>> Thanks. Good morning,
everyone.  First I just want to
say my thanks to everyone I've
gotten to collaborate on this
project.  Again, I don't work
with LC directly.  I'm employed
by another federal agency and so
this has been an incredible
project for me to work on.  And
if you ever get the opportunity
to work with LC Labs, it's
amazing.  So please take that in
consideration.
So what this slightly less scary
diagram here or chart is than
what she showed before is what
I've come to call the metadata
crosswalk.
So this is in other terms, a
metadata map.  And you'll see in
the first column to
your farthest side over here,
this is
the athor authoritative
reference for the map.  This is
the Merck data that the library
has related to their digital
collections from general topic
of baseball.  And to the next
column over, you'll find the
export.
So this is actually, as I think
Jamie mentioned through the
tutorial, you can learn how to
do a JSON API call and acquire
LC Digital metadata.  And we
used that.
We plotted that back onto the
Merc data and moved forward.
And the significance here is
that when we turned to look at
the national African-AmericanThe
National African-American
History and Cultures
collection and their metadata,
we had to bring it all together.
Holding the JSON data and
mapping it into the museum's
data was a significant point and
where we get to provide that out
to you.
And one of the
unifying factors was the next
column over from there, and this
is the Dublin core.  It's a very
common, simplistic
metadata schema.  And this
united the data such as what you
see in the final column and what
will be provided in the final
dataset.  Some significant
factors here to look at would
include the museum's attributes
field.  You'll see that in the
-- it's about third from the top
or fourth from the top, excuse
me.
And you can follow that through
and you'll see that's mapped in
a number of different fields.
So this is just some of the
intellectual work you have to go
through when looking at metadata
to explore where it needs to go
into the right
fields for proper use, for
proper querying and certainly
for unification
and bringing two different
unique heritage institutions
together, there's difficulties
but it's also kind of exciting
challenges to see that LC's
collection can very easily talk
through and with and form this
incredible dialogue related to
baseball and all of the subject
matter you saw the museum
present and what you get to
explore in our visualization as
well.
So with that I'll turn it back
over to Abby.  Thank you.
>> Thanks, Julia. It seems less
scary when you say it like that.
Okay.
So we started off the week
visiting our -- the baseball
Americana exhibit.  And we did
that to get us loose and
ready to play
.  The docents led us through
and told us the main themes
which are creating and building
community and paralleling
American history.
So this -- when we were sort of
walking through the exhibit, it
led us to ask sort of questions
about what we could do during
this week.  We wanted to know
what else our visitors might
want to see besides this
exhibit, as an extension of this
exhibit.
We wanted to know what other
stories our collections could
tell and what different
possibilityies of presentation
we could use because there's
only so much we can see in the
exhibit.
So in order to generate sort of
the
ideas Alex really talked, a nice
overview of what this design
session was
all about, we had some really
interesting ideas come out of
them that I think we'd like to
pursue later including sort of
different phone apps
and Snapchat filters, you know,
sort of fun things that we think
could bring our collections
closer to the people who want to
use them.
And this led us really to think
about audiences.  So we saw all
the work that JSTOR did,
interviewing the potential users
of our tools, and we saw how
careful they did those
interviews and got really useful
feedback.  You know, that
created a persona.
And when we were watching that
work, we thought, well, I think
with our collections, with our
exhibit, with our focus, we have
sort of a different user in mind
who's more of a lifelong learner
or a teacher who's trying to
teach people about community or
history and just baseball fans,
in general.
So those are the users that we
have in mind.
Following JSTOR's lead, we sort
of jumped right into user
interviews, and we quickly
created these mock-ups of how
we could display our
collections.
We used time line JS and one on
a map.  We used RTIF.  These
were tools that were quickly
available to us that we wanted
to, you know, try out, see what
would work and what people would
respond to.  And we did get some
useful feedback on
the concept of displaying things
on a time line or a map.  But we
thought that maybe we should
have -- we should sort of go
back and sort of kind of mirror
what JSTOR should have done and
start with a wire frame
and get sort of more information
about -- you know, because
there's a lot of -- when you're
working with a tool that exists,
there's limitations there.  What
we learned is we should have
started from square one and not
sort of skip steps.  We used
this for the remaining of our --
on the user interviews.  And we
got a lot of useful feedback on
this drawing.  We heard that it
could -- something like this
could be used in a classroom,
especially the time line aspect,
when teaching a subject
chronologically.  We heard that
adding datasets to our
baseball collections data like
census
data or income data would help
-- would help tell the story of
how baseball -- use baseball to
tell the stories like
the great migration or other
sort of big historical movements
that sort of take up the whole
country.
We also learned that it would be
meaningful to sort of plainly
show what the gaps in our
collections are, what we don't
have and is there a way
that we can see that clearly?
And we also learned that there's
users that have a lot of
knowledge about what we at our
institutions have.  But
knowledge that we don't have
about our collections.
So if they're interested in
contributing to and adding their
knowledge to the things that we
do
.  This rapid prototyping also
is iterative.  And like I said,
we shared this with
users, five users.  And with
their comments in mind, it sort
of helps us work through
challenges.  So this is -- I
don't know if you can
see this clearly, but this is
our subjects that we are dealing
with.  So we had 19 columns of
subjects when we brought all of
our collections together.
And this is really difficult to
show to a user.  As you can see,
the biggest sort of subject is
baseball card.  The second
biggest is color.  Is that
useful?  Is that -- so when we
keep -- when we
think of our users, it helps us
sort of work through some of
these decisions of
how we might present data about
the subject of the items to
users.
So I'm going to pass it over.
To either of you to talk about
the --
so this is the next prototype
sort of after the paper
prototype.  This is what Chris
made.  Do you want to talk
through?
>> So basically, we had several
stages here.
The first was getting all of
Joy's hard work pulled out of
the files which is one of our
datasets and geocoding so we
could put them on a map.  So
that was part of the early part
of the project.  We didn't have
a whole lot to show because it
was basically here's some data.
Here's the different file that
contains the same data in a
different shape.  And then we
started being able to do stuff
like put things on a map.  So
this slide shows -- I think this
was Wednesday -- Tuesday --
Wednesday, yeah.  Tuesday was
data wrangling.  Wednesday we
got this.  Can we go to the next
slide?  Oh, yeah.
So this is -- good thing -- so
we actually had three
deliverables.  So we had the raw
dataset for people
who are comfortable working with
CSV files directly.  We then
pulled it into a new
experimental tool called a
dataset which
is basically a database with a
web interface which is kind of
nice because we can take that
data, write any query you want.
You can browse through and see
what it is.  So for people who
want to be able to really do
advanced filtering but don't
want to write their own code to
do it, this is a nice little
intermediate step where you can
look on things.  You can tweak
it a little bit.  Some basic
plots and pull out the data.
And then the last slide here is
basically getting into the tool
we built, which was intended to
be sort of the general overview
to the collection.  So I guess
if we wanted to, we could go to
the Chrome browser at this point
and actually show the live
version here
.  But basically, the idea here
is this
gives you a way to view all of
the items in the dataset on a
map.  Having the ability to do
search so you can click on any
one of those pins, and you can
see the items that are in that
location.
You can click on an item and
pull up the information about
that and just scroll down.
It will pass the picture, and it
will
show the metadata, the
description.  One of the goals
that we didn't fit into the
sprint week was actually linking
all those things so that when
you see something tagged with a
particular subject, you could
then see everything else in the
collection with that subject.
And then the last thing here,
you can just close this.  Click
anywhere on the map because we
want to reset the selection to
the whole list.
And then you can drag that time
line slider.  It can be
adjusted.  And you can drag that
over.  And it adjusts the whole
thing.  And you can drag the
slider itself.  So if you wanted
to, you could pick, like, a
five-year period and then just
scrub that forward or backward
and see how the dataset changes
over time.  That will also work
nicely if you mention the -- if
you put anything in the text
field.  So if you're interested
in a certain team or league or
place that's mentioned in there,
you can filter all of these
together.  And so we were
thinking this is the raw -- this
is the basic overview of the
data, somebody who's getting
here first, they can get an idea
of what's in here.  They can
follow specific items back to
the source institution or up in
the toolbar, we also have the
links right now to the dataset.
And at some point there will be
a link to the explanatory
document that says here's how
you download this.  Here's what
you can do with it.
Here's the rights, the known
limitations.
And I really think this was a
nice way to just illustrate how
quickly we can give somebody an
overview for what's in the data
so that they can confirm that it
even answers the question they
have in the first place.
And maybe it inspires some
questions
about why we have so many pins
in a row in an obscure place on
the map.  Whether there might
have been some
confusion in what you were
searching for matches somebody
you hadn't heard of.  It really
is a good way just to narrow
that down interactively before
you've invested any time loading
it into your favorite data
analysis tools.
>> So one other thing we wanted
to focus on was the idea of
bringing in even more data.  So
we're already aggregating data
from our collection here at the
library and the National Museum
of African-American History and
Cultures collection.  So over on
the right side you'll see a mix
of items.  That helps
contextualize these items.  You
can look at them in location and
time and understand them.  But
as a researcher there may be
other information that you want
to overlay on top that helps you
understand those even more.  So
up on the top right of the map,
there's a control there where
you can actually turn on and off
other layers.  And we've got two
example layers.  The first one
shows stadiums.  So if you could
check that one on.  That layer
is actually from data we found
online.
So someone publicly made
available JSON did the that that
shows all of the current
stadiums in the U.S.  It was
easy to overlay that on the map.
You might find a dataset in a
standard format and bring it in
yourself.  Now you can make more
sense of the data.  The other
thing is we wanted to see how
hard it would be for us to make
our own dataset.  Thanks to hard
work on the team if you turn on
the second one, we built a
dataset that has team locations.
So this can sort of aggregate
with that other data, it gives
you a sense of where teams are
today and where they were.  And
you can start to look at how the
items correspond with those team
locations.  So this is just a
sort of hint of what you could
overlay on here.  It uses the
standard format.  So the idea is
you could bring in your own data
very easily and add it to our
collection and our data.
>> Great. All right. We can go
back to the presentation.
I think we're just about -- so
that link, that short link
there, that is where the current
tool is now.  We're also going
to be linking that
with -- on our experiments page
on labs.  And we'll continue to,
you know, work on it.
So what's next?
We do want to finish building
this.
And we do want users to come use
it
and give us feedback and add
different layers.  So we want to
give some instructions
on how to do that and sort of
more --
and we do similarly to JSTOR, we
are really interested in
different sort of crowdsourcing
aspects of how this kind
of presentation of data could
work.  We're interested in
adding different
organizations, different types
of data
to our set.
And continuing to sort of learn
more.  One of the big sort of
goals of this
week was just to sort of have
this week.  We're done now.  So
that was a complete success.
But we really want to sort of
model this same type of process
with other groups, other groups
inside the Library of Congress,
other groups outside of the
Library of Congress.  So we're
really happy with how everything
went.  We're really excited to
do more of this kind of thing
and share our
collections in different and
more ways like we've just showed
you, and like JSTOR just showed
you.  So with that, that is our
demonstration.  And we can take
any questions that you have.
And I should also say I'm sure
the other folks would take
questions if you have questions
for them.
We have a question, two
questions.
>> Could I ask you about the raw
data?
>> Yeah, we can go back to the
demo and back to the browser,
and then there's a raw data link
at the top.
>> I think you opened it. It's
those next tabs.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So this is the sequel
database that you created and
worked on?
>> The nice thing is if you --
>> Here.
>> If you click on items, you'll
see the raw item records.
But the other record -- and you
can see there's one issue we
didn't have to deal -- time to
deal with this week which is
normalizing multivalue items.
We have an answer for that.
It's just not ready yet.  But
basically, at the top there,
there's a sequel query builder.
If you wanted to, you could
filter
things and just do arbitrary
expressions for how to group or
coalesce things.  So one simple
example when we're looking at
the data, we have data coming in
from a number of sources.
And fending on what you might
want to use as a title for an
item, the answer can vary
depending on where it came from
and what metadata it had.
Sequel query, we could say pick
the first of these that isn't
empty and pull that in.  And
that makes it easier to give
somebody a link that shows them
things and not have to explain,
oh, for items like that go look
over in this column.  We can cut
that out.  You've done that work
once.  You don't have to think
about it again.  If we go back
and click on either the
geography or location columns,
these are also specific things
that were present in the
dataset.  And so one of the nice
things we were
able to geocode them and then
the viewer
-- oh, go back one more screen
here to
the main list of all the tables.
And click on either location or
geography.  This allows you to
view those directly.  It also
just puts them all on the map
for you.  So this is a great
way.  We were able to do the
data QA while the main viewer
was being worked on because
somebody else can go look at
that list and say do we really
have an item from this location?
Or confirm that the thing we got
out
of the subject list for
Salisbury, Maryland, was what it
geocoded to but it should have
been North Carolina.  And those
are the kind of issues that you
have for any dataset like this
where we're trying to link a
nonprecise entity to a real
value.  And that was great being
able just to
let somebody else do that
independently.  And this is, I
think, kind of a nice example
because you could also explore
this.
You could click on any entry in
that subject table and show you
which items it's linked to.  So
if you wanted to do some sort of
filtered query or just browsing
around that we didn't
anticipate, that's there as a
safety mechanism before you get
to the point of, well, now you
have to load the data and build
your own tool to query it.
>> Great, thanks. One more
question?
On a scale from first base to
home run, how fun was this?
[ Laughter ]
>> If this is also I was working
on this week, definitely a home
run.  I'd say a triple.  Really
great.  I work for OCIO so I
don't get to work with the labs
team all the time but it was
really wonderful working with a
really enthusiastic group of
people, having Chris on the
team.  Everybody just worked
really well together.  And that
certainly makes it more
enjoyable.  It was also fun to
go from having nothing to having
a functional tool and having
that tool validated by users,
listening to them say how useful
it would be, how they'd find
things they didn't think they'd
be able to find and all that
kind of stuff.  It was
definitely a great week.
>> Thanks.
>> Okay. All right.
>> I'm just wondering if you
have a data
visualization of the number of
baseball puns used throughout
the week.
>> We have a running list.
Yeah, I think our Courtney who's
been leading our communications
has utilized almost all of them,
I think.
But, yeah, that's a subgoal of
the week.  All baseball idioms
all the time.  All right.  Any
other questions?  All right.  If
there's no more questions, then
we will break for lunch.
And then we are back here at
1:15.
We will have a great panel
discussion with some baseball
experts, scholars and fans, and
we hope that you all come back
and ask your questions.  So
we'll see you at 1:15.
[ Applause ]
. .
. . . .
>>> Hello and welcome back.
To our Inside Baseball event.
For this afternoon, we'll have a
great
panel discussion featuring --
moderated
by our very own Meghan Ferriter,
senior innovation specialist
here at the Library of Congress
labs.
She's also a sports scholar and
will be acknowledged to our
grill our guests
-- not grill them -- but have a
conversation about baseball and
how it has influenced and
reflected our History and
Culture.  I'm going to announce
the panelists, and they're all
going to come out here.  But I
want to let you know that this
is being livestreamed.
And the video will be archived
at the Library of Congress, so
you will be able to watch this
again.  And again and again if
you want.
So first the panelists, Jordan
Ellenberg is a mathematician and
author, and he uses math to
uncover the hidden patterns that
guide our daily lives.  He's a
professor at the University of
Wisconsin-Madison and his book
how not to be wrong: The power
of mathematical thinking is New
York times' best-seller
and one of Bill Gates' ten
favorite books.  Clinton Yates
is a radio host, commentator and
columnist for ESPN's
"the undefeated" and a
Washington Post alumnus.  His
work examines the intersections
between pop culture, politics,
race and athletics in
contemporary American life.  And
then finally, we have Rob Ruck.
He is a sports historian and
professor at the University of
Pittsburgh, whose research
traces the dynamics of race in
majorMajor League Baseball.
He's recognized as an authority
on the
history of the Negro
leagueLeagues and Latinos in
baseball.  Ruck's repeat
publications include the 2011
book "Raceball."   So we'll get
started with our panel.
[ Applause ]
I welcome them out.
>> I think it only matters so
we're not so close to each other
that we can't hear each other
afterwards.  Thanks everyone for
being here.  Thanks to those of
you who have tuned back into the
livestream or if you were here
already, already have feedback
on things that would be
extremely helpful for sports
journalists and performing
research using cultural history
baseball cards.  And if you're
just tuning into the livestream,
again, you may have missed this
morning.  We had some sessions
where we were describing a
week-long process of exploreing
collections from the Library of
Congress, the National Museum of
African-American History and
Culture,
and articles in JSTOR and the
JSTOR databases which gave us
starting points of conversation.
But the whole reason that we
wanted to do this and connect
with you all is that we have a
baseball Americana exhibit here
at the library.  It opened only
about two weeks ago.  We are
hearing a lot of really
interesting things.  And we
started our week with a tour of
that.  We're going to end our
week with another tour of that
space.  And we heard from the
docents that some of the themes
that they are emphasizing and
the stories that they're telling
are around convening community
and paralleling America's
history.
So I wonder if Jordan, you want
to lead us and step up to the
plate first here.  Don't worry,
we'll talk about some language
and baseball idioms as well.
What are your thoughts around
the ways that baseball brings
people together?
Jk
>> Yeah, it's like batting
practice.
>> Also a little bit like a
softball pitch.
>> Well, at least for me, one of
the things that's so interesting
about the
community of let's say fandom.
That's not the only community
around baseball.  There's a
community of players, people who
work in baseball, et cetera, et
cetera.  When I think about the
community of fandom which is a
community that I'm a
part of, I think it's
interesting how chosen of a
community it is, right?  Some of
the communities that we're part
of we are born into.  You know,
we don't choose our family.  We
don't choose our history.  We do
on some level choose our team
that we root for, and yet our
commitment
to that, and I think for most of
us emotionally I think it feels
-- is it okay to say -- just as
deep as our commitment to our
historical communities that
we're part of.  And I think that
can be like a really good
learning to think about, like,
what
does community mean, if I feel
it so strongly at the same time
as I chose it myself, I could
have chosen something
else, in some sense it's
arbitrary as I think Jerry
Seinfeld said, you're rooting
for laundry, yes, but it
matters.
>> Clinton, Jordan's speaking a
little bit to passion.  And you
do a lot of communicating with
people in various media spaces,
on radio and TV and social media
spaces.  And I think social
media is a place where
interesting communities convene.
>> This is true.
Is Can you share something
that's either new or interesting
about communities?
>> Yeah, I think one of the
things that's foregotten about
history.  You can talk about the
history and the math, but in
sport itself, the communal
context of how it exists,
everybody has to watch two
people do one thing.  And that
is a very interesting
relationship in terms of how it
forces you to understand the
concept of team and the concept
of performance and the
concept of failure in, you know,
the communal sense.  And I think
that's a large part about
why people attract themselves,
baseball is attractive to them
and why it explains about how
you have to communicate.
There's an umpire.  There's a
manager.  Everybody on the bench
wears a uniform.  You know what
I'm saying?
It's very different
communication in
terms of the basic fundamentals
of the game that I think apply
to how people relate to it, you
know?  So the laundry in one way
is very important in a certain
way because
you're not wearing helmets.
You're not wearing shorts.
You're wearing pants and a
shirt, a button and a belt.  You
know what I mean?  It is very
much about a sort of very
normalized process that I think
brings a lot of people together.
When you talk about social media
and how different people come
toward it, everybody is allowed
to like as a result of all those
different things going on, a
different part of the game, you
know?  And that's very much, I
think, what attracts a lot of
people to baseball.
Most people who like baseball
probably don't even know how to
score a game, you know, but they
enjoy the environment around it.
They enjoy the sounds and sights
of the game.  Without even
necessarily caring what happens.
That's a large part that
baseball brings to the American
sporting landscape that I think
a lot of other sports have not
found a way to tap into and why
ultimately it is considered
America's pastime is because it
hasn't changed much.  And people
kind of like that because people
enjoy that in their communities.
>> Speaking about numbers and
people not being able to, like,
maybe create a scorecard, fill
it out, even read it afterwards
and know what different
annotations between.  We had a
lot of people who asked us
questions as we were working on
prototypes, were we going to
bring in statistical data.  We
said we want to put in some of
these cultural stories.  I
wonder if you can reflect on the
types of communities that formed
around baseball in Pittsburgh
and some of your work that
you've shared about those types
of teams and people.
>> I'm glad you're not asking me
a statistical question.
[ Laughter ]
>> I'm here, don't worry.
Jordan's got that covered.
>> You know, I'm much more
interested in what sport means
to people than the game itself.
And when you look at a place
like
Pittsburgh, where baseball was
the
sport, was the pastime for quite
a while, it no longer is.  You
see that it allowed different
groups of people to feel
included in a sense of
community.  I mean, that whole
notion of baseball as the
ultimate vehicle of
Americanization for the children
of
immigrants I think is pretty
valid.  Where that broke down,
of course, was over questions of
race.
And during the half century or
so that
the major leagues were
segregated, black Pittsburgh
created a sporting world of
itself.
And an amazing one with two
Negro League franchises.
7 of the first 11 men of the
Negro League selected to the
Hall of Fame came
to Pittsburgh and much more ever
since.
But you look at that community,
that black community, which was
fractured by geography, by
whether they were the old
Pittsburghers who had come from
the northern part of the South
in the 1890s, who were better
off, better educated and
lighter-skinned or those who
came during World War I and
after from the Black Belt who
were not, you saw that it
created a sense of community for
black Pittsburgh.
Which allowed them as the Negro
Leagues formed in the '20s and
had this
ak Pell archipelago to feel a
part of black America.  And I
think that had a profound impact
on the ability to build cohesion
and a
positive sense of collective
self which lasted for quite a
while.
>> Thank you very much for
sharing more about that.  During
lunch today we talked a little
bit about Clinton led us out on
this one, describing the ways
that professionalization of
major league sports may make the
sport less enjoyable.  So I
wonder if you can -- because
it's predictable, I should say,
not less enjoyable, predictable
in the sense of it's routine.
There's less variety.
There's less excitement over
what might happen.  And so I
wonder if you, Clinton, if you'd
like to respond and maybe lead
on your thoughts on this, some
of the ways that amateur sport
or collegiate sports and how
baseball formed in those
communities or in those spaces
tell us different kinds of
stories than professional
sports.
>> Yeah, I think that's actually
a large
part of why sort of
regionization of baseball has
led to the sport at the highest
level of not being as popular as
other leagues.  Major league
baseball acts like they're the
only form of baseball that
exists, when in reality, you
look at somebody like me, I grew
up playing baseball.  I played
here in D.C.  I can name you,
within, you know, a couple relay
throws, ten fields I've played
on in the city.  And that is
what baseball is to me, you
know?  People tell me all the
time, oh, my God, how do you
watch cleej baseball?  I can't
deal with the metal bats.  You
must not have played a lot of
baseball growing up.  That's not
real.  What are you talking
about?  So what I'm saying --
and the reason I
bring that up is because it is
-- it's
important to understand that,
like, what you're referring to
in terms of the Negro Leagues
and how that community came
together was about more than
just achievement at the top.
People played because they liked
playing baseball, and that's
what's cool about it.  You know,
you go to a high school game.
People show up.  The kids are
there to play.  They're not
playing to go to college.
They're not trying to
necessarily make the pros.  They
enjoy spitting seeds and talking
trash to their friends and
hitting the ball and picking it
up and putting it down.  If
you're yoonl understanding of
what the game is exists from
just the top level down, you're
really selling yourself short on
what a lot of the community of
baseball is.  That's why I go to
so many minor league games.
That's why I like coaching
baseball.  Because you're
involved with it on a community
level that is more than just
about the achievement, the
contracts, the trophies, you
know, and the TV time.  And that
ultimately to me is what
gives back a lot more than any
what I see on television.  You
know, it's knowing the people I
know from the game and what I
was given as a human in terms of
understanding what it takes to
you know, make it work.  And
that's still something that
sticks with me.
>> I mean, if I can jump in on
that.
>> Of course.
>> I mean, one thing, because I
spoke to from this top-town
point of view.  It's very true,
if you're a fan of your favorite
sitcom, you're not going
to set up four TV cameras with
your friends.  The only way
you're going to experience it is
through the professional lens.
>> Or turn it on YouTube, man.
>> Yeah, probably more now than
before.  As you think with
baseball and with respect to
regionalization, I grew up in
Maryland and hardly anybody I
knew played Little League.  Now
in Wisconsin, and what I have
learned is my son plays.  And I
go there and, like, there's
parents there whose kids are not
even in the game.  People in
Wisconsin, they'll just drive
down to the Little League field
because you know one of your
neighbor's kids is going to be
there and you're going to see
people you know or something
like that.
>> Right.
>> So I think it is really
different in different parts of
the country.  And there you see
this extremely organic kind of
fandom.  I shouldn't even call
it fandom.  Organic involvement
with baseball -- and if you
think college baseball is
unpredictable, watch
12-year-olds.  That's a
different story entirely.
[ Laughter ]
>> Tell me about it, man.
>> I'm thinking of two different
lines of thoughts.  I'm going to
put them together in the same
space.  I've heard a little
mention about some
of the artifacts or objects of
baseball, some of the things, a
metal bat versus a wooden bat,
the uniform that you wear, what
you're representing.
And in some of our work we're
looking at these collection
items.  We are thinking about
the data.  There's also the
representation of an image, what
does that show us?  And I
wonder, Rob, if you can share or
reflect on how some of the
spaces of baseball or items or
objects of baseball are changing
and how that connects to the
types of the forms of baseball
that we see played today or
other people have played in the
past.
>> Most of the work I've done on
baseball has been in the
Caribbean or in
black communityies, looking at
baseball
pretty much before integration.
-- artifacts.  What you have are
memories.  If you're lucky, you
find photos.
The amount of footage is scant
.  I think, you know, the last
25 years or so as baseball has
become
overcapitalized, there's
increasing stuff.  But in some
ways to me, it has less meaning.
It's noise.  The same way I feel
when I go to a
major league ball game, which is
why I
don't feel it's as enjoyable as
a minor
league or a Caribbean or a
little leagueLittle League game
because you can't even hear the
person next to you talk.
You feel overwhelmed by it.  So
I'm probably not the one to
answer your question.
>> No, I think that's a perfect
way to connect to spaces that
may be disappearing.  Go ahead,
clipt Clinton.
>> (Away from mic) I was there
recently and I wanted to point
out.  My mother is in the crowd.
She's from Kansas City,
Missouri.  The major league
baseball museum is there.
The What it does is, to your
point about things being scant,
that is very true.  There's not
a ton.  But there is a lot of it
there.  And what it does --
that's interesting -- and this
is not necessarily correlated, I
just thought to bring it up --
you realize that what it
chronicles is as much the
history of America as it is the
history of many things, not
necessarily baseball related,
you know.  And that's sort of
what, you know, speaking to your
point about how sports affects
people, you know, one of the
first women owners in sports was
in the Negro Leagues.  One of
the first times where they
played in those outside U.S.
communities first, be it the
Caribbean, be it Japan, be it
wherever, you know.
And it is scant, but it is not
nonexistent, you know.  And I
think that's why collections and
things of this ilk are important
because everything at some point
becomes scant because you can't
keep everything.  You know what
I mean?  But there are
collections that do these jobs
to keep around what, you know,
what people could.  And it's
really fascinating to look at,
you know.
>> Korea enforced that.
There's a reason why Buck
O'Neill was
the star of Ken Burns' work on
baseball.  And I think a much
more important
figure than Shelby Foot in the
Civil War.  And Buck's memories
and stories and reflections
steal the show.
>> Yeah.
>> But it underscores how much
your
point is that questions of
baseball or are questions of
American history.  And perhaps
no more so than when it comes to
race.
>> First of all, I'll second the
recommendation of the incredible
Negro leagues museum in Kansas
City which is I think one of the
best museums in America that
I've been to.  And that's also
to say I think what you say is
very right.  So I teach math.
That's what I do for a living.
And I find that one way I tell
stories about math as a teacher
is to tell stories about
baseball because baseball
touches math through statistics.
And in the same way, you teach
history, Rob, and because
baseball touches so many things,
as teachers, one
of the ways we can teach
whatever objective it is,
whether it's history,
whether it's sociology,
African-American studies,
whether it's math, we can teach
those through the lens of
baseball because baseball
touches them all.  It's not just
the story of American history,
but it is the story of American
history.  It's the story of all
those things put together.  I
mean, I meet a lot of kids who
don't think they care about
math, but they know they care
about baseball and which player
is better than another.  You may
-- I mean, you know, a kid who's
a little kid today.  You say did
you know there was a time when a
black man couldn't go to
Woolworth's?  What's
Woolworth's?  When you say not
everybody could play major
league baseball.  I think that's
as meaningful.
>> Oh, yeah, it's a huge
discussion in the sports writer
world.
I'm of the opinion before of if
you played before immigration,
they throw those stats out.
>> They didn't call it the white
league.
>> That's a huge point of
contention.  The most famous
players in people's minds played
long before integration.  Yeah.
>> I think the math people get
that.
>> Right.
>> If you talk about the
mathiest people who study
baseball, they understand that
there's a discount that you have
to impose and you can't avoid
that.
>> We've encountered that this
week in data that don't match
each other, the words that we
use with subjects we give things
as professional organizations
that categorize nsks, how there
may be a disconnect between the
stories we're talking about, the
oral histories, the discussion,
the ways that people talk
about baseball or life in
general, which includes
recounting being at a game or
being --
[ Lost audio ]
>> -- I was pissed.
They stopped giving away
scorecards.  I'm, like, what are
you doing?
[ Applause ]
Like you're instantly deleting
half of the reason why people
are going is to remember the
fact that they were there, you
know.  And if you kind of like
pay -- that is a huge part of
baseball in a way that I think
is very different than a lot of
the sports.
>> I think that connects a
little bit also to some of the
things we mentioned.  Just
briefly passing by before ways
that some of our collections
actually surface exclusions,
what's not there, different
types of artifacts that might
represent types of activities
related to
baseball, people, even roles.
We see a lot of players or
baseball cards that represent
players.  We have some managers'
papers.  We have oral histories.
But we don't necessarily have
all the stories where people are
reflecting specifically on their
experiences of baseball.  In
your respective fields, I have
to get a plug in about this.  We
have resources that may be
useful to you.  If you are going
to be looking for different
types of research or be
performing research and wanted
to connect with the Library of
Congress and its collections,
what might be types of objects
and/or collection items you
would be interested in?
>> Hmm.
>> I'm putting them on the spot.
>> You know, when I started
doing research, it was going
through microfilmed newspapers,
putting a dime in every time I
wanted to make a copy.
No laptops, no word processing.
And I kind of get angry when I
see how easy it is to look at
things.
>> Sorry, we're trying to make
it way too easy.
>> When I'm listening to all of
the stuff you have brought
together, I mean, I feel as if
there was a subject I was
interested in, I'd be
overwhelmed by the
amount of material and
information.  And it would seem
to be the next step is not just
to make all that universe of
material possible but figure out
how to
filter and prioritize so that I
can tell
my grad students to do it and
have high expectations.
>> This week -- oh, sorry, go
ahead.
>> I think what would be most
valuable to me, and I think
about this as somebody that does
a lot of television at this
point would be able to -- if you
could categorize how you see
things.  Like if I said I want
to see every homer that happened
on July 17th, 1988, you know
what I mean, around the league
or whatever, those kind of
specificities for visual -- even
I could listen to them, radio
calls or whatever.  That to me
would be cool because you
could -- for whatever reason the
way my brain works, to stay in
history and this kind of stuff,
really speaks to me.
And that -- that to me would be
a very valuable resource to
know, like, what was happening
on this day in the world?  Never
mind in a ballpark.  And can I
look at them all in the same
space and sort of compare them
and go from there as to how I
looked at the rest of the globe.
That to me would be really cool.
>> That's what I love about
images of old newspapers, right?
Because I could read the story
about the baseball game.  And
next to it, there's like a story
about, like, strak break strike
breakers and police or what's
happening in Asia.  You sort of
see not just what happened on
the baseball field but the
people who
were experiencing that in the
time, what else was on their
mind, you know what I mean?
That puts it in context.
>> Well, I promised we would
talk about baseball idiom and
language.  So let's talk a
little bit about the ways that
baseball is integrated
unexpectedly into American
vernacular.  As, Clinton, who is
a sports journalist, you
probably have to find ways to
not use sporting analogies all
of the time.
>> That happens for me because
I'm also a massive baseball fan
that talks in baseball lingo
just as a matter of course.
>> Yeah.
>> It's hard. I just realized I
did that earlier
when I said a couple relay
throws.  That's a distance I use
in my mind.  I'm going to listen
on this one.
>> Well, so we think about maybe
let's think about rather than
direct metaphors of baseball and
whether or not baseball, we can
understand other -- we're
arguing in our exhibit that you
can understand American history
through baseball or you can see
direct metaphor for particular
points in time or the ways that
people organize themselves.  Do
you have any reflections on
that, Jordan?
>> I mean, I want to say that in
some sense we're, like, the
exact wrong people to answer
this question because, like, we
are immersed and we hear those
words and that language a lot.
So we know what's being referred
to.  And what I suspect is that
for a lot
of Americans in 2018, they will
say three strikes.
>> Yeah.
>> But they may not even know
what that refers to.
I mean, when I was I compare it
to, think about how much of our
language is governed by nautical
metaphors.  You say somebody's
three sheets to the wind.  I
don't know what the hell that
means.  A sheet was attached to
a boat.
>> Maybe a mast involved.
>> Yeah, there's no way that has
something to do with a boat.
That's fossilized language.
That's gone.  Maybe if there's
any sailors in the audience, you
can tell me what it means.
To be honest, I think for a lot
of Americans today, a lot of
that baseball language is
probably like that.  There's
sort of, like, dimly aware it
has something to do with
baseball.  But they can't really
put a reference to it.  And yet
they know what sort of that word
means in English vernacular.
And you should ask them.
>> Not to mention, let's be real
about the incarceration policies
of this country, involving three
strikes and you're out.  That's
as real as it gets in terms of
putting people behind bars,
vis-a-vis the concept of a
baseball metaphor making sense
as to why you should be in
prison for the rest of your
life, it's kind of crazy.
>> We think of three strikes as,
like --
>> I would personally hate
baseball if I was in jail.
Like, yeah.  Because that's, you
know, but whatever.  That's sort
of a different discussion.
That, to me, that's drilling
down as far as you can go.
Taking away people's freedoms
based on the notion of what
happens when you're
in a batter's box, based on a
pitcher and a catcher and
whether or not -- like that's
crazy.
>> Picking up on a little bit of
a thread that you had, Jordan,
of you not being the right
people to ask.  I disagree.  I
think you're the perfect people
to ask these types of questions.
But I also wonder -- kind of
related to what you're both
talking about, taking baseball
out of its context, and there's
this could be a slightly
controversial view or it could
be something you think is true,
this idea of a decline of
baseball as America's pastime,
that should it still be
America's pastime?
>> I don't think there is a
national pastime anymore.  I
mean, I think that sporting
interests are fractionalized.
Clearly the NFL is the most
successful economic sporting
league in U.S. sporting history.
Even that could be some sort of
existential crossroads for a
number of reasons.  You know, I
look at my students, and I've
been teaching the history of
sport
since the late '70s at the
university ofUniversity of
Pittsburgh.
And it was easy to discuss
baseball and to have that common
shared knowledge.  And I think
Jordan's point is right on the
money.  They don't have the
language anymore.  They don't
have the memory.
I can talk about Bill Mazz Roz
Mazeroski and Clemente or Lionel
Messi.  I think we're past that
point where we have one
collective sporting experience
that is defined by a single
sport.
>> I'll tell you this, though.
And this is something that I
don't know that it's -- I know
that a lot of Americans take for
granted.  If you go to another
country and you throw something
to somebody, they will likely
take it as an assumption that
you were throwing it at them and
not to them.  And that is a very
interesting thing about how -- I
mean -- I'm saying, though, like
-- no.
[ Laughter ]
You get my point.  You know what
I mean?  On a very interesting
base level, whether or not they
care about
leg-league baseball big-league
baseball, the simplest part of
the game is integrated into our
society.  Hey, catch this.
It's not going to freak you out.
You're probably going to catch
it and you'll probably be able
to send it back without much of
an issue.  That's why I think
baseball will not change as the
pastime.  It will simply exist
in a different part of our
brains as a sporting level.
But what the actions are are
very much ingrained in who we
are in society, you know?
Throwing and catching is pretty
standard American operation, you
know.
>> That's a perfect segue into a
question about whether or not do
you view baseball as an
international sport?  And I
think there's maybe certain
places in the world that we
think of as connected to the
United States through baseball
in a professionalized way, but
you may also have other
reflections that you want to
share about amateur or community
sport.
>> I mean, I think it's both. I
mean, I think baseball, more
than it ever has been, is a
world sport.  But it's also a
world sport whose home is the
United States.  I don't think
there's any contradictions there
that the U.S. is kind of the
temple.  And I think it's still
true that, like, the greatest
world players, their ambition,
is to not play in Korea, like
not play in Taiwan, not play in
Mexico
but to play in the United
States.  Yeah.  And I kind of
like about it that it's -- but
it's a different mix, right?
It's not the NBA has become a
world sport, too.  It's a
different mix of countries.
Baseball has this kind of sort
of a Pacific orientation, right?
Where it's, like --
>> I wish.
That's going to be the death of
major league baseball is being
concerned about being too
American.  That's really what it
is.  You look at the culture of
the game, you watch the World
Baseball Classic where different
nations fill different squads.
You've seen this with your
scholarship on the Caribbean and
so forth.  It's a totally
different concept than what the
game even is.  From an
entertainment standpoint, never
mind a participation standpoint,
it has to be global in order for
it to survive.  And that's sort
of the large mistake I think
that the big leagues is making
is that they're trying to make
is very much
the sort of Puritanical nonsense
that's boring.  You know, you go
to so many different places.
And it's just -- it's more fun.
It's a different thing.  It has
to be global in order for it to
be, I think, real for a lot of
people.
>> You watch the Baseball
Classic, people from different
countries, they're not playing
in the same style as American
players.
>> 1,000%. Oh, yeah. I mean,
we could break this down on a
strategy level.  We could break
this down on a style level.  You
could break it down on a
communication level.  You know
what I mean?  That's the way
people talk.  The way that
people run bases.  I don't know.
The aggressiveness with which --
the strategy of the game.  It is
very different in different
places across the globe for
sure.
>> (Away from mic) the kind of
this is how it's done.  It's not
done this other way.
>> Yeah.
>> And I 100% am in agreement
.  I've never noticed the
players who break those rules, I
feel like they're
less likely (away from mic).
>> Okay. I'll give you a great
example of this.
Clint Hurdle is the manager of
the Pirates.  Hurdle was a
number one pick in the draft.
Hurdle hit, like, 40 bombs in
his ten-year career and he's
been managing in the big leagues
for God knows how long.  He's
not a good manager.  Bobby Baez
is probably one of the most
exciting players in all of
baseball.
Javy Baez hit a bomb and Clint
Hurdle went off about how this
is not how you do this and that.
And I'm, like, Clint Hurdle was
a bum compared to Javy Baez.  He
didn't even appreciate the fact
that he was celebrating
something he had done well.  I
mean, that right there showed me
exactly all you needed to know.
Random white guy who was not a
very
good players felt the need to
scold, you know, a young Latino
player who was showing too much
emotion for what he felt was
appropriate to the game.  That,
to me, is a massive problem with
baseball.  Just as a matter of
course, in general, you know
what I'm saying?  You know what
I mean?  We're going to have
fun.  We're not here to talk
about unwritten rules.
>> I'll let you slide on Hurdle.
[ Laughter ]
Don't dis.  Getting back to your
question.
The major leagues have always
seen themselves as a temple of
the game.  And they've always
wanted to dominate.
But frankly, MLB was never the
only game of baseball.
And 100 years ago, the best
white and black players went
down to the Caribbean and played
winter ball.  During the summer,
players from the Caribbean came
and played either major or Negro
League ball depending on whether
they passed for white.
The demarcation point is
integration.
And in the years after that,
particularly with the expansion
of different media and the
ability to
broadcast, the games and the
islands and
in Mexico increasingly suck into
MLB's commercial orbit.
And that's what I think is
deadly
.  I agree with you toegtsly
about the style.
A Cuban game, dminian game,
Nicaraguan game differ from MLB.
But what's even more fun is the
style
and the stance
where it's just not piped-in
music all
the time or, you know, per
pierogi races.  It's just real
action.  It's a far more
exciting experience.
>> That might connect back to
this idea of community and
experiencing a game you
mentioned -- we've heard this a
couple different times in the
conversation.  We've talked
about coming together in a fan
lot style and how people share
information or connect with one
another or the way they
anticipate or plan their runs to
the bathroom or next snacks
because they know what's coming
ahead or
they want to get on the camera
if they're in a professional
sporting space.  So what are
some of the ways that you think
baseball might provide -- and
Jordan, I'll maybe ask you to
speak to baseball as an
experience, provides
opportunity for people to come
together or learn something new
about the place that they are.
>> Well, I'm suppose to talk
into this now?  Okay.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I'm going to say
something, like, very simple
about this because I think
there's this very primal thing
where in your life, it's
actually pretty rare that you're
among, like, a large group of
people whose attention is
focused in the exact same place
on the exact same thing.  That's
an uncommon experience.
>> All of us here today.
>> All of us.
[ Laughter ]
All of us who are not on our
phones are having that
experience.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, okay, it's a little bit
embarrassing, but I took my kids
to theThe Eclipse last summer.
We drove down to Missouri and we
went to The Eclipse.  Standing
there in this big field with all
these people all looking up.  I
was, like, oh, yeah.  This is
like baseball.
Everybody here with this big
huge crowd all looking up at
this round thing in the sky.
All in the same place.
So I don't know if that
experience, if it's meaningful,
it's meaningful without actually
meaning any particular thing,
right?  It's meaningful in this
very primal way that I think it
feeds some kind of
desire for math mass experience
that we rarely are offered.
>> From an experience
standpoint, I'm not really sure
this answers the question.  It's
something I wanted to highlight
because of the sort of the
situation but
a couple years ago when there
were riots, I'm using air quotes
for those of you listening on
YouTube, in Baltimore.  The O's
played a game where they locked
out the entire stadium.  They
didn't let anybody into the
ballpark and they played a major
league baseball game.  I was
there.  There were probably 50
people there covering the game
which was a super bizarre
element of this.  I remember
thinking at the time we
have really failed as a nation
on a lot of fronts if we're
legitimately playing baseball
games in front of nobody.
[ Applause ]
You know what I'm saying?  For
the sake of the game continuing
but the actual experience being
robbed because of some concern
about something that may or may
not happen outside of the
ballpark.
And it was eerie on a lot of
levels.
And to the O's credit, this
year, they've instituted this
thing where you can bring your
kids to the ballpark for free if
they're under 10 and you can sit
up in the crowd because nobody's
up there anyway.
[ Laughter ]
That's not a knock.  That's a
legitimate way to get people in
the ballpark.  The reason I
bring that up is it was such a
stark contrast of how in the
same place different experiences
can be so
different and such a profound
impact on a community.  And I
remember talking to people, you
know, around the ballpark on
what I called the ghost game
were mad.  They were, like, who
does this, you know?
And now, you know, Camden Yards
is one of the nicest ballparks
in America.  To me, it was an
interesting example of the
evolution of what I think it
kind of needs to be.
Let people in the ballpark and
people will like the sport more.
That's pretty obvious.  To me
that's a large part of the
experience.  It's the biggest
thing people will see in their
lives in one place.  You should
let people experience that.
>> You know, I think the best
thing about sport is when you're
playing it yourself, when you're
participating.  The next best
thing is when those who are
competing are people you know
and care about.
We get further and further
removed
till we become these consumers
primarily on TV or on our phone
or something of
people who live in different ZIP
codes.  And I think if you flip
it
historically with baseball,
between World War I and II,
there were 400 or 500
independent baseball teams in
western Pennsylvania.  We had
two Negro League teams.  You had
the Pirates.  But the
independent sandlot and
community teams drew far more
people each week than the
professional clubs.
And a lot of the people who were
playing were people playing into
their 40s or 50s.  And 40 or 50
was relatively old.  And they
were playing in the neighborhood
where people could walk to work,
walk there after work, throw
some
money in a passing hat, and
either see people they cared
about or be a part of the
action.  And that to me is when
sport provides the most
community.  I think we've gotten
several steps removed from that.
>> I want to pick up on
something that you mentioned
earlier, Clinton, and you had a
little bit of a conversation
about this about some of the
greatest players playing before
integration and also the ways --
so we've got a couple of
cross-cutting threads here.  I
have only two more seconds.
This is the second to last.
So this is a question that's
about what types of patterns
that you've seen in history,
Rob, and Clinton and Jordan,
maybe thinking about the numbers
and what types of what would you
think is
the most important type of
statistic or form of playing
baseball or pattern from players
in the past that we've lost in
today's game?
>> Oh, I mean, if you mean -- if
you really mean statistics, then
I think the answer is nothing, I
think the statistical richness
with which we understand the
sport today is vastly greater
than it was at any point in the
past.  I think we have
everything we had in the past.
>> Numbers are consistent over
time and other things have
changed.
>> I mean, well, apart from the
fact that as Clinton brought up,
differences
in playing, who was allowed to
play and who the competition was
and who was pitching to you.
That obviously is something you
have
to do separately from that
standpoint.
You know, I think age statistics
gets
started in the late '70s, early
'80s, makes it a mass-market
thing.
>> Does everybody here know who
Bill James is?
>> I'm leaving it people don't
know who Bill James is.  He
brought kind of modern
statistical analysis of
baseball.  People were doing it
but Bill James
was the person who was, like, I
can sell my books from the B.
Dalton and Waldenbooks.
>> Further away.
[ Laughter ]
>> He was the guy you had the
belief that, like, I can make
this, like, a mass-market thing.
Now you go to Miller Park in
Milwaukee, there's OPS and WHIP
on the scoreboard.  It's there
for everybody to see.  I did not
think I would see that happen in
my lifetime.
>> Right.
>> I'm of the of the party --
maybe it's obvious that I would
be -- who thinks that's a good
for baseball.  I don't think
that replaces our fandom with
spreadsheets or number
crunching.  I think it just
adds.  It doesn't subtract.
>> I'm interested to hear what
you think about this in the
terms of statistical forms of
baseball -- you know, all this
other stuff.  I imagine this is
not very popular in your world.
>> I stopped understanding math
after Woodstock.
[ Laughter ]
Among a lot of other things.
>> Wow, what did you take?
[ Laughter ]
>> You know, when you look at
all the stats, you just don't
have that for black baseball.
>> Right.
>> You don't have that for the
Caribbean.
You're using a ball which would
have
been thrown out, you know,
scrapped but hit the ground.
Once in the majors, these guys
might have played most of a game
with it.  They're playing with
terrible lighting on fields that
are not going to give you a true
hump.
So the statistical stuff for
that era mean little to me.
You know, that Joe DiMaggio can
say Satchel Paige is the
toughest pitcher he ever faced.
Or when I would talk about the
Negro Leagues in western
Pennsylvania and have guys who
played for their coal miner
team, white guys, stand up and
tell me how proud they were that
Josh Gibson hit a home run off
them.
>> Right.
>> That resonates with me. You
know, the stuff you see in box
scores from those days, it's
shaky stuff.
>> Right. And when I watch a
game now, I mean,
the fun part is the stat -- I
mean, the stats are part of the
game in the context of it is
part of the notation.  It's part
of the record.  Like I said, I
keep score at games.  That's
different than statistics,
obviously.  You know, that's
just -- that's a part of the
game that I'm not going to say I
don't care about because that's
not true, but it is not -- it is
behind the action, you know?
And that's -- but that's also
why it's cool because you would
never -- you know, you don't
remember these things.  That's
what they're there for.  But,
you know, the most important
stat to me is the one everybody
forgets about most, which is
runs scored.  The player that
scores the most is typically the
best player on the team, just so
you know that.
>> Actually, can I kind of --
can I follow up on that
question, too?
>> You may. Of course.
>> Am I allowed momentarily?
>> Of course.
>> When I think about what's
different the way the fans today
experience baseball, I don't
think actually the new regime of
statistics makes that much
difference.  I think as you say,
what people are watching is did
the guy cross the plate or not?
That's what they're watching.
But what I think is truly
different is to the extent that
people -- interaction with the
business of the sport is part of
their fandom.  And you brought
it up and you talked about how
it has become more distant and
more of a consumer operation.
It kind of blows my mind that my
son who's 12, he loves playing
baseball games on his phone.  He
has one game.  The hitter and
pitch comes.  He tries to hit
the phone to make the bat hit
the ball.  He has another game
where he's the GM of a baseball
team.  And he thinks of both of
those as baseball games on the
phone.  You know what I mean?
And I do think that for this
generation of fans, thinking,
okay, like, how many
compensatory draft picks am I
going to get if I trade this
player?  It's part of what
they're thinking about.
Not is their base going to get
over to make that play.  That's
a little foreign to me.  And I'm
curious what you guys think
about that in terms of this next
generation of fandom.
>> There's games based solely on
that, like video games.  Actual
consoles where that's all you're
doing.  I don't need that,
personally.  I mean, that's not
a knock.
>> You're like the old man
portion of the program.
[ Laughter ]
>> Well, to be fair, the reason
I don't do it, because I'm not
smart enough to get a handle on
it.  That's what it comes down
to at the end of the day.  I
like playing.  That would be the
easy part.  Figuring out the
other nonsense is hard.  That's
not for me.
>> One last question and I'm
going to connect it back to our
collections at the library.
We recently digitized Branch
Rickey's players and we heard a
lot of feedback publicly from
people who were surprised and
excited to see different kinds
of information within the
scouting reports and
correspondence.  And my question
is what is an enduring myth that
you think you would like to
either dispel or you've recently
myth busted yourself about
baseball?
>> Interesting question.
>> You can take your time.
>> Well, I think a story worth
noting about Branch Rickey that
may not necessarily go in the
myth context,
though, is that -- I'm not going
to say that integrating baseball
was not the most important thing
that he did because I don't
believe that.  But people don't
know that Branch Rickey tried to
start a third league.  There was
a national league, American
league, and he tried to start
the Continental league.  Like I
always think about what would
have happened if that had been
real, you know what I'm saying?
>> Like a great pilot.
>> If he managed to pull that
off, like some third league
where the big leagues were now
-- there was, I don't know,
insert 15 more cities where
there were
big-league teams now,.  I think
about that all the time in terms
of who he was because it was
more -- like he wasn't just some
dude trying to get, you know,
one brother into the bigs.  That
wasn't what he was.  He was a
totally larger baseball mind in
terms of so many different
things from a business -- and a
growth standpoint.
And that oddly gets forgotten a
lot.  Which understandably,
obviously Jackie Robinson is
important to America and
baseball is huge in Branch
Rickey's involvement, but that
dude was much bigger than that
in terms of the specificity of
the sport and trying to
grow it on an expansion level in
terms of squads.
>> Not to pile on Branch too
much.  You know, I think whoever
described
him as the person that talk
Machiavelli the strike zone was
on the money.  And, you know, I
thought you were going to talk
about the fact he built a farm
system in the '20s which
monopolized hundreds of kids.
>> Right.
>> For the Cardinals. You know,
Branch Rickey gets a lot of
credit, and I think a lot of it
has been demolished for
integration.
He's not doing it over a social
conscience question.
>> Right.
>> He's doing it to monopolize
talent, win championships, and
improve the bottom line.
And, you know, to me a more
interesting proposition would be
what if they had brought in
Negro league clubs in the late
'40s?  And the Negro League
clubs after integration, which
witnessed their fan
base crumble overnight,
petitioned Major League
Baseball, bring us in as a high
minor league.  MLB didn't even
answer.
And you could, you know, if that
had
happened, then you wouldn't have
the Pannis movement in 1987
where there's no black managers,
GMs, front office or ownership.
We're a little bit better now
but not all that much.
>> Not by much at all.
>> Well, thank you so much for
chatting with me exclusively.
Let's open up to questions here
in the room.  Oh, we've got one
right there.  Enthusiastic.  So
we have some microphones we'll
bring around.
>> Hi. Charles Martin.
Thanks to Rob Ruck again for
your blurb on my book "Lawyer
Ball."   I'd like to make a
statement and a
proposal regarding
the Stultifying of baseball, the
existential turning point of
baseball.
I suggest that they have the
same -- they relate to the same
problem, and they have the same
solution, which is
that baseball, thanks to the
major
league ss and to the congress
hose whose library we're sitting
is one of the few legal economic
cartels.  And Mr.
Yates, the couldn'tContinental
league would never have
succeeded because baseball would
have used its 1922 Supreme Court
exemption from the
antitrust laws to kill it.  This
is how economic cartels behave.
They do not innovate.  They kill
competition.
And the way to solve the
existential
problem of people like Rob Ruck
no longer enjoy going to
baseball games.  Baseball games
taking three hours.
Kids not knowing who Mazeroski
and other people in history are
is competition.  You introduce
competition.
You will save the game.  The
game is great.  It's hard to
kill.  But Major League Baseball
and Congress are doing their
best to kill it.
Are you going to applaud?
[ Applause ]
>> Hi, this is Gates Ward. I
was just wondering if you think
that we'll see a woman play in a
nonexhibition Major League
Baseball game.
>> No. And I think the reason
for that is because I would
rather just watch women
play baseball against other
women than I
would necessarily some, you
know, notion of egalitarianism
through competing against men.
I have a huge issue with that on
a lot of levels mainly just
because, for example, Serena
Williams is my favorite athlete
of all time.  When I say that
she's the greatest
tennis player of all time,
people are, like, you mean for
women, right?  No.  And
secondarily, that's not what
that is, you know.
And I -- I would like to see
more opportunities for women to
play baseball, period.  And if
it has to come only in the world
in the framework of doing it
against a man, that's a major
problem.  For me.
[ Applause ]
>> Questions relating
to the stairs.  The first
question is the exhibit focused
a lot on the evolution of
baseball.
And I was wondering what the
panel's position was on the
current changes in the baseball
rules, whether it be
raising the mound as, what, 20
years ago or introducing the DH
or even the new rules that
they're trying to speed up
the game by introducing
different things.  As an
historian or as an ESPN
commentator or as a
mathematician or statistician,
how does that change the
game each time they introduce a
new rule, or does it change the
game for the better or worse?
>> I mean, I'll just say this.
As a mathematician, I value
elegance a lot.  And I think
this concept of having a runner
start on second base is the most
cockamamie thing I've ever
heard.  I can't even say whether
it would make the game better or
worse and it's just ugly.  I
oppose it on that ground.
>> (Away from mic).
>> I went to a game in Nashville
probably a month ago.
In AAA, they've got pitch clock.
What is it?  It's 30 seconds
between batters.  15 seconds
between pitches.  20 if there's
a runner on base.  And, okay.
You know, like whatever.
Conceptually, do I have a
problem with this.  And then I
realized my only issue with it
was that there's clocks on the
field.  The cool thing about
baseball is there's no clocks.
That's like the whole point.
And there's four o'clocks
around.  There's a constant
countdown happening
in your mind which was a little
bother shm. some.  But then they
played seven innings,
that bay bad boy was over in
like, 2 hours and 15 minutes.
Okay.  Maybe I can kind of deal
with this.  So I'm not really
sure because on the surface,
it's annoying.  But it worked,
you know?  It kept it moving.
And if that's what your goal is
for baseball, then sure.
But my position on this has
always been that it's the nature
of the game.  Batted balls and
so forth.  What happens during
the course of the game is what
changes people's excitement.
Not just the length of time.
Inserting seven dudes between
the
sixth and the ninth for matchups
is annoying.  You know what I
mean?  That is far more
aggravating than just the amount
of time it takes.  You're
constantly stopping and
starting.  And what you're
getting as an action is not, in
fact, that exciting.  That to me
is a larger issue that people
don't actually like what's
happening.  Not necessarily how
long it's taking in any matter
of time.
>> We have time for -- sorry,
Jordan.
>> That's okay.
>> One more question if it's
quick.  And maybe another one
after that.
>> Okay. I'll try to make this
quick.
Do you think that the owners'
preoccupation with making money
in the major leagues especially
has limited the
availability for familyies --
and obviously it has -- to go to
the game, but the importance of
going to the game, having the
same experience as somebody like
me that grew up and is 50 years
old now would go to the game and
end up behind home plate even
though I bought a ticket out in
the outfield, and now if you try
and go and do that now and have
that same experience and
actually hear the communication
between the dugouts and the
umpires and the batters and
stuff is just -- you don't have
the same experience when you go
to the game when you go with a
family of four to a game.
>> I'll say this. One thing I
think modern baseball is doing
right -- and irritates, too -- I
think the modern baseball
stadium, the cheap, faraway
seats are really good.
That wasn't true when I used to
go to Memorial Stadium in
Baltimore.
I go to Camden Yards and like
buying expensive seats
sometimes, show off to my kids.
When I sit in the bleachers, you
really feel in the game.  I
think it was not as true in the
older stadiums.  In one respect,
they're doing more to equalize
the experience.
>> That's an excellent point. I
hadn't ever really thought of it
that way.  The stratification
between the best and worst is
not necessarily that different.
You know what I mean?  I hate
sitting behind the plate.  For
me it's a bad view and you're
looking through a net.  I don't
actually like that seat.  But I
do think there's something to be
said about the family
experience.  Then again, when I
go to baseball games, I really
kind of only see families.  I'm
not really sure what the other
side of that complaint is
because well, yes, it is
extremely expensive in the basic
concept and the value of a
dollar,
like I don't -- I don't know who
else is going to ball games.
You know what I'm saying?  It's
not like people are walking in
off the street that much
necessarily outside of random
businessmen.  Which by the way,
I never understand, like
businessmen specials.  Why is it
called that?  Like what is this?
That's such -- that's such an
antiquated term.  There are
still a lot of families going to
ballparks.  And without delving
into the intense economics of
why it costs so much to go
to games, you know, it's still a
fun experience.
And that to me is hard to
evaluate.  If you don't like it,
you don't like it.  If you go
there, you're probably going to
have a good time.  And that, to
me, is effectively the most
important thing overall.  No?  I
mean, does that make sense?
>> I would just add that I think
smart franchises in the smart
sports are cultivating kids and
building them as fans.
And I've seen the
penguinPenguins do that in
Pittsburgh by making a large
block of tickets available at
moderate prices to college
students.  And the success of
the team is helped.  But, you
know, I think, for example,
in Dominican Republic, before a
game, you'd see 30 or 40 kids
seated on the outfield walls
with poles, with nets at the end
to try to snag balls.
And they'd become lifelong fans
in the process.
>> I think we will wrap up here.
I want to thank everyone for
joining us in person and also on
the livestream and especially
thanks to Jordan, Clinton and
Rob for spending the afternoon
with us.
>> Thank you.
>> If you were watching, we will
be archiving the livestream.
We'll make that available to
you.  We encourage you to visit
-- what's that?
Forever on YouTube.  We
encourage you to visit the
exhibit if you haven't seen it
yet.  I think I will pass back
over to Abby to wrap us up here
on this event.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Well, thank you so much.
That was such a great
conversation.  I wish it could
be hours longer.
>> (Away from mic).
[ Laughter ]
>> I don't know. The Tigers.
Transition year.  It's fine.
[ Laughter ]
But this is just a very short
wrap-up just to thank everybody
that came, thank everybody from
the JSTOR team who's
still around who really made
this week very just packed with
-- I want to use baseball
idioms.  I can't think of them.
It was a really wonderful week.
I think this conversation just
put a big exclamation point on
it.  And I just want to thank
everyone for coming and tuning
in.  And thank you, Meghan, for
moderating that nice
conversation.
>> Thank you, Meghan.
[ Applause ]
>> And go see a baseball game.
And go to the library.
(The ceremony concluded at 2:32
P.M. ET.
)